peu
[Musique]
m
bongo bon bah bien venu sur le plateau
de tout le monde en parle
l'émission dont tout le monde parle avec
nous ce soir mon avis tommy bugzy elodie
navarre mode sa route aux non musulmans
chirac
c'est un chien d'une stèle
anne béatrice dos
bérégovoy s'est il vraiment suicidé
brian molko's placebo
heures calixthe beyala
notre plainte est consacré ce soir au
travail puisque cette semaine c'était le
premier mais mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
ça
qu'est-ce qu'ils font corps en matinée
[Musique]
avant de recevoir mon premier invité
jours et qu'on regarde on sent les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
vous savez comment ça s'appelle et vous
savez par qui s'est préparée manitoba
serbe connaît dès votre plus jeune âge
on vous apprend votre père dit les juifs
sont des cochons et vous êtes obligé de
de ne pas les aimer c'est le moigne à
toi longtemps je commence et ce grâce à
marie thérèse qu'il m'a dit je sais les
juifs et ça c'est les gens comme toi
comme moi tu dois les aimer plus dure
que j'ai passé deux voisins boucherie
juive et j'ai acheté la viande et je
trouve c'était la première fois et j'ai
trouvé la viande est excellente comme
d'autres vous voyez votre mère clic
étouffe les filles à la naissance avec
une couverture c'est-à-dire qu'on fait
quand c'est un garçon qui n'est bon le
laisse vivre mais quand c'est une fille
a de fortes chances qu'elles soient tués
à la naissance accès mendes i wanna 4 à
5 si si ça va mais dès que ça passe un
peu plus là c'est la mort de sa mère il
est venu vers moi et m'a dit toi tu es
enceinte bien attendez je rêvais pas les
dire oui c'est mon papa et ma maman il a
proposé mais tu est carrément je compte
faire la lessive et à mon beau-frère et
leurs idées le message ici je vais
t'aider
tu dois bosser gentilles va m'aider et
plus tôt que ce que je sentais la baie
mais l'essence sur les cheveux oui vous
sentez un liquide froid malades
je sentais les pieds de froide sur la
tête et je sais pas c'est avec une
braise avec une allumette je sais pas
tout puisqu'il chef j'avais le feu sur
ma tête j'ai commencé à courir dans les
jardins en tapant des mains sur mes
cheveux
et puis je sentais les bébés elle bouge
à l'intérieur de mon ventre et pc
l'aller au hasard ils ont éteint les
feux avec l'eau les couvertures les
journalistes vous m ah oui c'est sûr moi
je vous aime beaucoup ça va lui voir mon
spectacle parce que j'ai autre chose à
[ __ ]
alors vas-y ça fait 20 ans qu'on se
connaît
pardon ça fait 20 ans que je n'avais pas
beaucoup changé je remercie vous êtes
très flatteur vous êtes un fieffé faye
ont finalement en asie ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que votre liaison avec
nicolas sarkozy
ça n'a pas eu tellement de conséquences
sur votre carrière
ça je vous laisse les jurassiens ont
tout de suite c'est injouable même pas
en rêve même à 10 ans voit sa note je
suis sans nom je préfère lui mois sur
une île des siens je préfère me faire un
dauphin croissance je suis comme tous
les occidentaux je suis habitué à une
définition du nihilisme très occidentale
le nihiliste posséder c'est celui qui
croit que tout est permis
parce que dieu n'existe plus loin cela
je pense que tout est permis
parce que dieu existe y compris des
coupes et égorgé un homme un juif le
découper en dix morceaux recomposée ces
dix morceaux les bras les jambes coupées
allen le trou en la tête les pieds pour
l'enterrer on a l'idée on se dit ben
laden c'est une crapule etc
enfin au moins il y croire un saut au
moins c'est un ascète qui vit dans sa
grotte dans son désert dans son tora
bora et qui fait don de sa fortune à la
cause de la révolution c'est le
contraire c'est un mec qui fait du fric
ce sont des gens pour qui le djihadisme
l'intégrisme musulman
c'est une manière d'acquérir du pouvoir
et de l'argent
vous avez ici un état pakistan qui n'a
pas que vous disiez casile armes
nucléaires non c'est un état nucléaire
il a la bombe atomique il a il est doté
d'armes de destruction massive et ses
armes de destruction massive sa doctrine
officielle aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
doive proliférer c'est qu'elles doivent
aller sous forme de bombe sale ou de
bombes miniaturisés dans les mains d
les assassins qui croient à la guerre
des civilisations
tu fais le pitch non je fais pas lui je
raconte un peu l'histoire d'accord je
croyais j'attendais qu'ils me posent la
question tu veux pas faire le pitch vous
avez commencé
il se dit j'ai fait un film à la drogue
non c'est pas bien d'ailleurs je veux en
profiter pour janvier vois tu fais pas
passer ses messages
c'est pas bien la drogue les américains
ont dit qu'ils allaient faire une pause
se retirer pour prendre des forces pour
revenir sur la glace et bien et on dit
qu'il ya eu une négociation et que faire
cela négocier son départ avec par la
jirs là en échange d'un renoncement de
renault et son armée à ce moment là il
ya bien eu quelque chose qui s'est passé
ça ne donnait qu'une ville imprenable
sauf si on la donne et le pape lui même
s'ils s'étaient déplacés par un de ses
derniers voyages c'est ça qu'il fallait
il fallait qu'il soit bouclier papale
voilà le bouclier papale ça c'était un
beau concept inventé il se serait
installé au palais la fait bien fait
beaucoup quand même
oui mais ce serait installé au palestine
malouche n'aurait pas bombarder voilà on
peut gagner une guerre militaire mais
gagner une guerre politique c'est autre
chose et gagner une guerre culturelle
c'est encore plus difficile en soi
largeur médiatique
oui mais ce qui est en jeu dans la
modélisation des systèmes d'information
de communication c'est qu'il va falloir
admettre que les autres cultures les
autres civilisations même ça nous parle
nos moyens techniques nos moyens
culturels et nos moyens économiques
elles sont aussi riches que nous un
paysan irakien il a cinq mille ans
d'histoire dans sa tête parce qu'on a
fait l'écriture la bravo je pense
exactement
les américains avaient tout pour
comprendre que le monde entier était
hostile à cette guerre et que personne
n'en voulait ils avaient tous les
systèmes d'informations officielles et
non officielles et n'ont rien compris et
on m'a dit c'est pas parce que vous avez
toutes les informations qu'on prenait
les commandes y a pas pire sourd que
celui qui veut pas entendre c'est juste
ils ont rien compris
preuve qu'en définitive de l'information
et la communication ben ya un sacré
chemin et c'est à ce fait d'autrui tout
à fait vous avez raison vous diffusez ce
discours dont vous refusez en vérité
d'avoir votre responsabilité c'est ça
n'en vaut ma responsabilité elle et de
dire aux téléspectateurs
faites gaffe il ya des cinglés qui coupe
le bout des capotes pour filmer le sida
à d'autres gens je encore une fois
n'avait pas tu ne le savais pas donc
nous on l'a découvert par votre émission
je pense que si un petit scandale dans
votre émission a pour conséquence des
contaminations et ensuite des cadavres
mais que ça vous fait gagner quelques
points de dymat ce n'est pas un problème
cette émission fait 30% de parts de
marché régulièrement depuis des années
elle a pas besoin de scandale pour
continuer à réussir va vous voulez
porter aucune responsabilité sur
l'attention alors que sans vous le
bareback n'existerait pas c'est à dire
que médiatiquement c'est vous qui avez
donné une audience vervaeke
moi je veux dire une chose ya deux
théories dans la vie il n'ya pas de
liberté pour les ennemis de la liberté
et ja je ne partage pas vos idées mais
je suis prêt à mourir pour que vous
puissiez les exprimer
moi je suis de la seconde catégorie
voilà
j'ai préparé par monsieur jaune
messieurs
[Musique]
bah
m
j'accueille maintenant ma vie
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va alors ça va très bien et
toi
très bien alors que l'invitée surprise
ce soir oui bah oui comme j'ai vu que tu
y prenez goût que ceux qui ces mystères
c'est tout à l'heure en attendant
gigean
voici stomy bugzy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon
c'est bon ce tome i bon soir donc un cd
et un film dans la même émission
c'est top avoue là ça fait plaisir ça me
fait plaisir vous kiffez la life la save
en ce moment ça veut dire prise et la
vie je le dis pour ma mère et mon père
ouais alors stomie on va commencer par
le cd1 la musique et puis ensuite on
parlera du film assez bons il faut alors
le dernier morceau c'est une femme en
prison featuring kelly rowland des
destiny's child bravo quand vous l'avez
connu on avait en avaient travaillé
ensemble sur un remix avec les destiny's
child pour une radio et là j'ai envoyé
les textes les textes les textes radio
en vue du titre une femme en prison à la
doré doré le sujet ça n'avait jamais été
fait souvent le morceau de rap on parle
de présent mais on parle plutôt de les
deux hommes réputés les mecs et là c'est
un hommage rendu aux femmes en prison
elle adorait l'a été a été touché par sa
haine du west mais en plus il a une voix
sexy ça m'a fait très plaisir
[Musique]
qui était forte
oui ce sont ensemble comme la trique une
certaine dose de lâcheté
alors silence pour lesquelles on
aperçoit social course à label qu'elle
applicatifs en quelques secondes tout
encore précipice jeune femme tiens toi
[Musique]
qui
une femme en présence de me dodji
culture et camions
destiny child and the way you lie alors
je vais te dire un truc chez nous à
langue c'est le sosie de ma grande fille
1 alors cet extrait d'un album qui vient
de sortir qui s'appelle quatrième round
[Musique]
quatrième round 4 ème album de stomy
bugzy alors ces dernières années vous
étiez plus présent stomie devant les
caméras que derrière les micros et là
c'est le grand retour du prince des
lascars dans le rap
ouais j'avais envie de j'avais envie
d'envoyer d'envoyer la sauce j'ai
l'envié de ce que j'avais dans les
tripes dans le coeur dans les poumons
j'ai mis du temps à le faire d'utile mes
albums gelé bouclant si cette mort là
j'ai mis deux ans à faire un an et demi
deux ans rendra bien je suis vraiment
content tout abus alors oui la chanson
dont convient d'entendre avec kelly
rowland est aussi un duo avec passi et
puis avec nos faibles qui est un prodige
extraordinaire un jeune mec qui font du
challenge d'arrêt il joue de la guitare
c'est incroyable il a 15 ans tout de
suite c'est un génie la chanson
s'appelle viens avec moi
bah
[Musique]
tu orlando exige le clip
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
pas ce soir
fois si tu as peur du noir moi perso
nous fera baisser les bras aux
montagnards des frappes deviens moi tu
as besoin de moi comme j'ai côtés
d'olivier facile avec les hôtels et ça
s'appelle viens avec moi et c'est sûr
qu'à grande
voilà alors nous retrouver vos potes à
vous retrouver pas si justement que tu
es avec vous à l'époque de ministère
amer bah si vous l'avez connu au bac à
sable c'est quoi c'est une moyenne
elle appelle content d'y être connus
très jeunes quoi et puis un jour vous
écouter la radio nova vous entendez pas
si je vous dit [ __ ] c'est lui le rap
et pourquoi pas moi ouais comme on
l'appelle déjà ensemble à l'école h en
traîneau un collège donc quand je
l'entends du radio nova faux j'ai aussi
ouais alors sur quatrième rang il ya
aussi à médailles dans une chanson mais
sa mauvaise habitude
alors quand on vous parle de ses
mauvaises habitudes que vous aviez à
l'époque de minister hammer et avant
l'époque de sacrifice de poulet ou
l'époque de brigitte femme de flic
quand on vous parle de ça vous dit
ouais je recommencerai pas mais je
regrette pas ouais quand c'est clair que
quand on a 20 ans on veut faire la
révolution on veut tout détruire à tout
reconstruire voilà et après en
grandissant des choses qui changent
oui je vais un peu de compassion
maintenant pour les flics qui sont sont
molestés qui sont agressés dans les
cités où j'étais j'ai toujours eu de la
compassion pour les flics qui font bien
leur boulot voilà fait qu'il fait bien
son boulot il en faut sinon ce serait
l'anarchie
ouais ouais tout marque quand tu te fais
tu te fait tabasser tu te fais voler
chez toi qu'est-ce que le premier
réflexe est quoi j'appelle un peu les
mains ok alors que mon contrat je suis
afrique qui fait bien son nom n'y a pas
de problème par contre des flics qui
font des bavures bassin alors vous savez
vous savez stomy bugzy que de nombreux
syndicats de police sont émus de vos
déclarations sur le fait que vous ne
regrettez pas des chansons comme
sacrifice de poulet ou brigitte femme de
flic et ce soir c'est vrai qu'ici c'est
une émission débat cette émission où on
discute ce soir nous avons deux
représentant d'un syndicat de police
les voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir donc messieurs vous êtes
du syndicat national indépendant de la
police française
vous appréciez pas tellement finalement
quand il quand il dit qu'il regrette pas
parce que brigitte femme de flic quand
même c'était un peu c'est un peu l'arbre
c'est une femme de flic qui se fait
sauter partout le monde quoi
écoutez monsieur ardisson ouais je suis
vraiment ému surtout que ma femme
s'appelle brigitte a choisi dubois et
m'écoeure moi j'ai parlé il faut lui
parler vous êtes là pour débattre c'est
un moyen de ses ouailles où ça se voit
de suite huawei
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter boyoud
[Rires]
quand vous restez avec nous vous avez
envie d'intervenir pendant les mictions
l'a toujours besoin d'avoir des gens qui
ramène un petit peu le débat dans le
droit chemin alors stomie est ce que
votre fils bilal est au courant de cette
époque comme ça de sacrifice de poulet
ou deux oui il connaît tout dire ouais
qu'on est des paroles par coeur de tous
mes albums d'un grand militant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
story on va faire une interview expliqué
à mon fils papa papa c'est quoi un
sacrifice de poulet
c'est un rituel un rituel vaudou qui se
fait quand tu veut arranger
quand tu va arranger des problèmes et ça
se fait beaucoup en haïti ouais papa qui
c'est brigitte et brigitte c'est une
femme que un soir
un soir je marchais à sarcelles et j'ai
vu une femme en train de pleurer des
lycées sous la pluie qui avait été
violentée donc comme je suis très galant
j'étais l'avoir et je vais je vais
demander alors c'est quoi votre problème
pro vous pleurez madame je déteste voir
une femme pleurait donc elle m'a raconté
un peu ces histoires tout ça et j'en ai
fait une chanson tous ces voix ne peut
pas à l'école et un garçon qui arrête
pas de dire que tu t'es embourgeoisé ah
bon oui aux 80 ans souffre encore
beaucoup pour que ton papa il
s'embourgeoise
là bas c'est vrai que quand je suis né
tata arrêter tes conneries
oui totalement dès que tu es né j'avais
ce déjà sorti mon premier album du
ministère amer pourquoi tant de haine et
dont j'ai arrêté un petit peu la musique
je suis retourné jouer à l'anpe ouais
j'ai pointe allen peu j'ai trouvé un
boulot de deux tireurs de câbles dans un
hôpital à chelles les câbles dans les
égouts pour te payer ton landau états
chambre et qu'est ce tu faisais papa
avant quand tu déconner tu faisais quoi
comme genre de déconne à plein de trucs
ton papa quand il était petit il faisait
partie d'un gang voyous
la pl plein plein plein de trucs des
petits trucs mais il paraît que tu es tu
es gentil papa parce que des fois quand
aller cambrioler chez des gens tu voyais
les photos d'eux et de leurs enfants ils
n'osaient pas les prendre et il préféré
tirer des ordinateurs dans les bureaux
c'est vrai papa oui ça c'est vraiment
fils
ouais oui mais c'est pas bien tu avais
un bon coeur quand même pas pas un
gangster d'amour ouais c'est vrai qu'à
un moment qu'ils allaient travailler
avec pépé sur les chantiers tu
transportait des sacs de ciment sur ton
dos papa oui et aubin c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tu as plein de sous et à
acheter toutes les îles du cap vert
non j'aimerais bien vraiment bien avoir
pleins pleins de sous pour arles et
aimant le problème et non j'ai j'ai un
petit peu de sous pas beaucoup combien
tu as exactement en ce moment je suis à
découvert en ce moment de combien vous
ma chère découvert de 50 mille francs va
pas on ira au cap vert tu es déjà allez
monfils mais tu étais très petit tu
avais quatre ans à genève depuis je n'ai
pas retourné c'est vrai mais je
t'emmènerai l'an prochain et devront
passer de la drogue comme la nasa
et il ya un gars sans l'école il a dix
ans qu les papas ça veut dire quoi
c'est une grâce eu ça veut dire que ça
veut dire [ __ ] bcmo ses saveurs
vraiment rien dire ça veut dire ça mais
ça veut dire connard ça veut dire ça à
l'eau ces enveloppes landen lors pas et
s'ils me le diamant [ __ ] papa qu'est
ce que je dois lui faire tuer même pas
gérer une petite soeur bientôt papa
inch'allah papa tu m'aimes pas je t'aime
puisque tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vrai stomy bugzy chanteur on passa
stomy bugzy acteurs avec un film qui
s'appelle gomez et tavarès voilà avec
titoff que nous avons reçus la semaine
dernière avec elodie navarre noémie
lenoir et jean yanne voilà tu faire le
pitch en jeu c'est le pitch
alors ça se passe à marseille il ya une
strip teaseuse qui disparaît et elle
réapparaît à paris voici et la diva
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir il dit
alors c'est votre première télévision on
est très très heureux que ce soit dans
tout le monde en parle donc dans le film
vous êtes une strip teaseuse vous
disparaissez et heureusement il ya
tavares alias titoff et carlos gomes
alias stomy bugzy qui arrive pour vous
sauver
voilà bon titoff c'est le magouilleur
vous vous êtes l'incorruptible ambitieux
coriace
machiavel froid - droit tout ce qui est
plus classe dans la police oui vous avez
quelque chose à ajouter
voyou mais moi j'ai posé une question en
suspens il dit ça t'a fait quel effet
après tant d'années nous avoir insulté
d'être retrouvé dans la peau d'un flic
dans un film quoi tout simplement quoi
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est une très
très bonne question
ouais c'est vrai que quand les petits on
veut tous être soit pompiers soit être
souhaite policiers être flic donc ça
implique
à l'écran c'est jouissif pour un acteur
il ya des choses à défendre il ya du
suspense de l'action il ya de l'émotion
en plus de films ils réussissent à des
forêts donc en tant qu'acteur faire un
flic à l'écran c'est payant il ya des
choses à défendre leurs tué deux
pompiers
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter boyoud
regarde avec majordome manitoba 10 16
d'entre connais je vais l'addition des
30 euros 40 cents voilà je vous hais
l'âge est bien homogène on m'appelle
arrêt ça parce que l'inspecteur harry à
côté de moi c'est une [ __ ] moi quand
je m'énerve ça pique
vous allez faire équipe avec max tavares
c'est un peu le héros du coin bâillon et
toi là bas tu en état d'arrestation
kwassa kwassa coups et blessures sur un
yacht d'annapolis veux mais tu pu
classer droit s'il te plaît un homme aux
joues paris nice qui s étend ramires qui
pose des problèmes gomez
contrairement pour acquérir un nouvel
état sur toi tu entends c'est qui ton
temps maintenant c'est bon tout le temps
combien tu as sur toi 250 noms ça ira
pour aujourd'hui mais demain ça sera le
double avec sa fille qui est trop gros à
18 ans j'ai regardé son cul moi j'ai
fait ça
bravo les gars la prochaine fois j'aurai
besoin de protection je m'achèterai un
caniche va peser comme ça ouais on y va
doux jésus
[Musique]
sarrio j'étais bien motoko la dragonne
ses calèches de gildas des bois leur
tient ce soir mercredi
monsieur chez nature est incertaine le
lire
comment ça s'est passé alors accéléré le
bonheur est retourné avec titoff est que
gilles paquet brenner
c'était vraiment un bon souvenir un bon
temps dans ce sens a été envoyée depuis
deux mois ils font une petite apparition
ces deux salles au bar au début oui
voilà prêts peu le pognon quoi alors l
audi vous est superbe dans une scène de
strip tease au début du film
c'est une belle revanche pour vous qui
avez eu un grave accident en grèce vous
a été renversé par une par une moto et
cela dit vous rembourse un petit peu les
longs mois de rééducation vous avez
exposé subi quoi c'est une belle
revanche parce que je pensais vraiment
pas pouvoir la danse et et d'ailleurs je
n'osais pas le dire à gilles quand j'ai
lu dans le scénario
ouais donc dans le système éducation
vain mot à dire au médecin de garde qui
sont dupes et vous laquelle celle-ci
alors professeur judée venez voir ce
film même si vous êtes très occupé le 7
mai venez voir cette scène de danse que
j'ai faite grâce à vous ouais
[Applaudissements]
j'oubliais le cers 15 ans de rééducation
de sportifs de haut niveau chez qui j'ai
pu passer quatre mois et qui m'ont
réappris à vraiment marcher correctement
ses emplettes ronaldo acheté en même
temps pris à bas les après la part de
strip tease de mouvement et oui oui pour
les danseuses moi je prends bien dit non
même dans les pires moments vous n'avez
jamais voulu abandonner
non je crois que c'est ce qui m'a donné
encore plus de forez on était retournée
et bien alors il ya une jolie fille dans
ce film c'est noémie lenoir
alors cet ami a déclaré une fois très
belles phrases seulement le lover sto du
serment de le séducteur et dans le film
vers des extrêmes manque raconte je dois
dire mais il a dit je peux tomber
amoureux d'une voix d'un regard d'une
main mais là je crois que ça a été tout
à la fois avec noémie no bravery un mois
et demi n'est pas là ce soir c'est pas
grave soumis on va vous faire une
interview
noémie lenoir
[Musique]
donc tu es noémie lenoir noémie noémie
cela était trop dur de jouer la soeur de
stomie dans le film avec non pas du tout
j'ai beaucoup de caractère et je sais je
sais le tenir les garçons à distance et
voilà mais quand il t'offre vous drague
ça a dû le rendre jaloux stomie
normalement non non parce que c'est un
acteur et des très professionnel et
voilà et qui comprend les choses il a
beaucoup de charme un sommier à noémie
oui ça va c'est un vrai lover lover
noémie il est un pareil il est génial ce
tome i know me qu'est ce qui vous a
attiré chez stomie quand vous l'avez vu
comme ça pour la première fois à l'essai
lui sa timidité sa timidité ouais c'est
vrai qu'il a un côté comme ça toujours
apeurés un peu réservé un beat mois
noémie on vous a dit que on l'appelait
bugzy parce qu'il baiser comme un lapin
non
ça c'est la réputation qu'il avait avant
mais s'est calmé je devais une sage
maintenant c'est en plus il paraît qu'il
est vachement on vous l'avait un peu
serré nos amis ça vous dérange pas
noémie de sortir avec un mec plus petit
que vous non mais pas il est très malin
que quand on fait des photos ensemble il
se met sur la pointe des pieds donc ça
sera pas juste moi noémie dernière
question vous lui avez dit pour
l'histoire entre entre nous deux ce tome
i ah non il ne s'est pas seulement il
vous enverra un verre avec titoff et le
dynamo
et jean yanne et c'est le 7 mai
dans un cinéma
et maintenant
moi c'est de notre faute
[Musique]
bonsoir claude ça va très bien il est en
bonne compagnie la elodie navarre sexy
boy who
alors claude à par le journal le monde à
part les émissions de laurent ruquier à
part le théâtre vous êtes l'auteur de
nombreux livres dont le dernier publié
chez plon s'appelle d'ivoire mamie net
[Musique]
alors le personnage central de ce roman
cm minettes et 76 ans une vraie battante
un cas vraiment la pêche
et puis qui discute avec ses filles
adoptives and it s et carole elles
passent leur temps à se moquer d'elle en
fait mais elles peuvent pas se passer de
ses conseils n'ont tous les problèmes
qui ont les jeunes femmes maintenant 1
et elles sont les problèmes grecs leur
carrière avec leur leurs beaux enfants
et familles recomposées tout ça et moi
je suis terriblement de ce conseil ne
vais pas me mêler de leur vie tu vois
jusqu'au moment où à la fin du livre
vont dire qu'elle en a un peu marre tout
agacé donc par ce racisme anti vieux qui
en ce moment comme il ya le
politiquement correct maintenant tu pu
taquiner ni les noirs les handicapés y
les familles les juifs lui
alors est ce que les vieux moi il
restera et je me bats pour moi pour les
yeux et vie
[Applaudissements]
laurie leur sens dans cette chanson a
légué ya déjà des vues handicapés des
vieux et des vieilles femmes
le fait qu'on se moque d'eux parce
qu'ils sont vieux oui ça c'est pas bien
moi je suis heureux je respecte beaucoup
d'eau 3ème âge vous êtes la seule
vedette seniors du paf claude la mamie
du paf vous dit plus je vieillis plus
j'en profite quand même oui maintenant
je vais m'en fous je dis ce que je pense
plus aux dix plus ont dit la vérité puis
on est libre est la vérité qu'est ce
qu'on ferait est-ce qu'il peut m'arriver
tu peux me dire de vous priver de la
shoah au seuil et de menaces envers mais
plus j'en ai pris de dhr de quoi ça
réveille la libido marche tu as une
catastrope après 70 ans
ah oui alors trouvant les vieille dame
de 70 ans et plus dont on réveille la
ridt la vidéo c'était très frustrant la
plupart n'ont plus de partenaires ah
ouais bah stomie des potes à moi claude
oui en même temps pourquoi pas monsieur
des sentiers sur le papier pourquoi pas
en fait attend une grande maison un
grand frigo l épeautre asylum c'est très
vrai un petit jeune de 17 ans claude ça
vous plairait pas un petit jeune de 17
ans tu vois je trouve ça opsens a
imaginé on attendait claude
claude sérieusement c'est pour pas
trompé jean françois revel c'est parce
que je n'ai pas envie j'en ai plus envie
je j'ai dépassé ce stade tiens voilà
encore une liberté tu t'en fous d'avoir
un mec tu sais quand on a fait beaucoup
l'amour et à un moment on commence à
voir album ah bon mais oui on se lasse
et vers quel âge que l'autre dans la
mare à moi il n'y a pas tellement
longtemps que tu avant-hier j'ai
beaucoup fait l'amour dans votre vie
beaucoup j'adorais ça
moi je comprends vous prenez un peu de
dh ha ça va réveiller votre libido et
copain de stomy bugzy haye mais
l'affairé dans le sac
claude équipe est 4ème et dernière fois
avec 5 m habile il faut montrer tes bras
pct vieille cuisses des fesses qui
tourne en rond tamise un peu on prend
l'argent et on s'en va alors parlé aussi
dans votre livre de la virginité vous
dites jeune fille je préservait
jalousement ma virginité pour être sûr
de dégoter un beau partir c'était mon
petit capital et samedi d'abidal comp la
secal connaissions à l'époque
évidemment on n'allait pas le vélv des
comme ça tu sais la rue marque la plus
extraordinaire que j'ai entendu c'est
quelqu'un qui disait c'est absurde qui
n'est pas vierge ne va pas acheter un
paquet de cigarettes jetés mais tu te
rends compte je ne doute pas c'est égal
60 ans et que cette année entre un autre
monde une autre époque c'est important
aujourd'hui c'est tommy la virginité ça
dépend des coutumes et des religions
mais là où c'est dangereux c'est comme
quand une femme a connu qu'un seul homme
dans sa vie
après plus tard et des fantasmes qui
verrait la sexualité des filles se
développe beaucoup plus tard que celle
des garçons
un ado un garçon de 16 18 ans et d'une
conduit par son sexe ne pense qu'à une
seule chose baiser baiser une fille pas
du tout si elle veut être aimé aimer et
mais voilà alors quand elles se fondent
et plus c'est trop tôt et sont pas
heureuses pour autant vous êtes d'accord
avec toi elodie c'est vrai une première
expérience assez mauvaise donc jeu
ben claude aussi à une expérience assez
mauvaise la première fois à l'âge de 12
ans il était à moitié violée par un ami
de votre père c'est violent c'est un
test dans les familles parce que c'est
la famille ce sont des enfants comme moi
peut dire mais plaît alors les tontons
paie autant même ton père
il te perds reste tu vois les prolonge
les caresses qu'on te fais à 6 mois 2
ans 3 ans et tu prolonge et moi ça me
faisait plutôt plaisir ça me flatte est
plutôt et donc il est arrivé à sa très
naturellement
c'est vraiment pour que je pense je
recommence à hurler je me sens mais
est-ce qu'ils sont les services est que
là bas non je voudrais que vous dites à
2000 violé et votre peur il l'a su que
son pote voudra y ériger son service
militaire à l'époque il l'a su compter
arrivé en permission
tout ce qu'il a fait il a expliqué aussi
que c'était un fou que c'est un malade
quand j'ai rencontré ce premier mari
américain oui ben stanley week bat là il
a mis six mois à me dépêche les chaque
fois qu'ils s'approchaient de l'endroit
stratégique usées attention tu es malade
schéma là tu vas pas là au bout de six
mois ça a été ouais c'est pourquoi non
parce qu'on s'est formidablement disputé
à rien de plus affreux génial aller
disputer ce cas là je me suis enfin
ouverte avant que j'étais comme ça
elle vise
alors claude dans votre livre vous
parlez aussi de l'adultère et vous dites
de mon temps quand on trouvait deux
billets de cinéma dans la poche de son
mari on y penser deux fois avant de
demander des explications quoi ont
laissé un petit peu voilà ont laissé un
petit peu glissé le truc on faisait un
petit dîner aux chandelles on mettait un
petit déshabillé affriolants et puis
voilà ça s'est passé quoi c'était dans
tous les magazines féminins ces français
qu'on te donner à l'époque c'est très
nadine de rothschild oui il arrivait
seul en tête devant la télé dans des la
main pour qu'on lui mette en wifi dans
la main et quand tu te mettais à ses
genoux en ayant soin de doute
d'entrebâiller ton décolleté il faut pas
que tu que tu fous là qu'est ce que tu
fais que tu vas tu es folle ou quoi tu
vas et tu recevais et à gifles et
agissent le moral c'était l'époque de 5
à 7 quoi voilà il y avait du bruit ya du
bon et du mauvais 1 cave où plus de
mauvais que de bon dans mon temps de me
le faire maintenant
ah oui j'ai l'impression que les femmes
sont beaucoup plus heureuse maintenant
beaucoup plus heureuse beaucoup plus
libre elles font ce que je trouvais
qu'il fallait faire j'ai toujours fait
d'ailleurs elle a un mec les trempant
elle lui rendre la monnaie de sa pièce
au sous près et pas de m'être déshabillé
faire la danse du ventre ça ne sert à
rien si c'est mieux alors tout ça c'est
des souvenirs que vous avez que vous
écrivez peut être qu'un jour quand vous
serez dans votre maison de retraite
haute vous y penserez qui pensent déjà
je m'en souviens bien d'un claude eux on
va vous faire une interview maison de
retraite
[Musique]
lui vous m'entendez la ba oui vous
voulez voir quelque chose oui une
verveine une camomille riddle du
champagne du champagne la tension ça va
la tension a oui bien sûr ça va bien ça
vous fait quoi de piquer le boulot d'une
jeune qui en plus perdre votre temps moi
j'ai assez cotisé pour la retraite de
mes anciens à fait normal qu'elle petit
pour la mienne vous fait quoi de savoir
que plus personne n'aura de nora de
retraite après vous oui j'y crois pas je
crois que tout le monde aura la retraite
savoir les manifestations la semaine
prochaine les obligés de verser des
retraites
si vous fait quoi quand on vous
reconnaît dans la rue ça me fait très
plaisir et si vous fait quoi quand vous
reconnaissez personnes dans l'assam
soulage ça vous manque ma chance aux
chansons que j'ai jamais vu la chance
aux chansons
ouais il se passe quoi en ce moment dans
amour gloire et beauté tard mais moi je
le vois pas non plus je regarde sex and
the city sanaa
claude science vie normale
un ton roman publié chez plon
e
[Musique]
et maintenant tu es surprise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors tu va nous poser des questions à
faire un petit jeu là personne apte à
répondre par oui ou par non de la tête
vous êtes un garçon non dit la vérité
toi aussi
vous faites de la télévision est ce que
vous êtes âgés un petit peu c'est à dire
genre 40 50
oui vous êtes écrivain vous êtes
féministe actrice a débauché en tout cas
vous avez vos papiers
vous avez fait de la télé il ya
longtemps des niçois vont pas loin à à
danièle gilbert
non
[Applaudissements]
oui
khadir effectivement après maître
capello j'aurais dû m'en douter
danièle gilbert comment ça va bien je
serais bien heureux de pouvoir donner
moi aussi ben voila et puis vous avez
participé à l'émission j'espère et
maintenant alors sûrement vous appelez
qu'un petit ou when i grow museau qu'un
premier renaud muselier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien
mono muselier jeta me jean françois roy
ne vous souvenez de sarnaut un peu leur
surnom n'a fait qu'un petit ou voilà un
surnom qui lui est resté enfin bon
maintenant vous êtes quand même
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
affaires étrangères dominique de
villepin vous avez déclaré d'ailleurs au
quai d'orsay c'est dominique de villepin
qui fait tout et moi je fais le reste ce
qui fait quand même pas mal de trucs à
faire
il reste ya de quoi s'occuper il est
mieux habillée que la dernière fois tout
ça m'apprend qu'il est un peu là pris un
peu j'ai pris quelques rides alors
effectivement dans cette plage point
important parce que c'est vous qui êtes
parti en chine avec raffarin c'est une
contrepétrie pas du tout en pleine
épidémie de pneumopathies les partis qui
veut embrasser qui veut embrasser renaud
muselier claude maintenant
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes médecin
oui absolument mâcher la réducation
fonctionnelles - ouais neurologie
regardez sa jambe de minutes à l'heure
mais apparemment ça s'est passé super
super ce que tu arrivé jeudi absolument
alors comment ça se passe dans ces cas
là parce que normalement quand on va en
voyage officiel comme ça après les
dîners quand on arrive dans la chambre
des filles qui attendent c'est normal
c'est les coutumes asiatiques
donc là qu'est ce qui se passe avait pas
de gonzesses dans les champs ben c'est
surtout c'est que ce que j'ai découvert
dans ce genre de voyage et ça on fait
quand même quelques-uns depuis dix mois
il y à des officiers de sécurité devant
la porte des officiers de sécurité
derrière la porte des officiers de
sécurité dans le couloir et donc on est
en permanence protéger ça ne laisse pas
tellement ça pour les autorités de bâle
alors ça si tu veux te taper le c'est
pas interdit un ânon [ __ ] et être mais
bon non mais sérieux dans ces cas-là il
ya pas des gonzesses dans les chambres
même pas mise à part ce nom sont sympas
ils sont très sympas mais c'est l'achat
pour ne pas garder avec est ce qu'on
fait ce soir avec dans la chambre y
ajouter fatigue était grande et trois
airbus en vitesse à pompey
tu m'invites est sérieuse ou est ce qu a
dit chen ipsx dans les pornos chinois du
portail dans les pays arabes mais dont
douze au pays oui alors votre grand-père
l' amiral emile muselier gaullistes
historiques inventeur de la croix de
lorraine doit être satisfait de vous non
de se retrouver aux affaires étrangères
porter l'étendard de la france - au
moment où la france a beaucoup de choses
à dire internationale ben c'est fait
partie de de mon éducation de ma culture
d'arriver à se retrouver dans une
responsabilité politique où on peut
démultiplier la voix la france aux
nations unies ou à travers le monde bien
c'est quand même une certaine marie
alors non seulement vous êtes le petit
fils de lui de muselier mais en plus
vous êtes le cousin de l'eca premier
d'albanie vous saviez sa clinique i les
parents que le roi d'albanie comme lampe
à brax s'avère non pas ma mère c'est
c'est la soeur de ma mère la soeur sa
mère a épousé le roi zaugg le fameux
roisin le roi des aigles voilà le roi
des aigles les méchants à peu c'est un
peu la syldavie l'albanie alors donc
vous allez est en charge maintenant
renault sérieux tout ce qui concerne
l'humanitaire en irak faut savoir qu'en
ce qui concerne les difficultés de
nourriture en irak
tout ce qui fait aujourd'hui au niveau
international world food program c'est
hier le pam dans le monde entier eh bien
rien que pour l'irak ça sera exactement
les mêmes d'efforts voila voila landes
la taille l'enjeu donc c'est la
communauté internationale qui s'en
occupe et au niveau français on a
débloqué beaucoup d'argent va aider les
ong
on est sur place sur le terrain on a
amené 30 tonnes de matériel déjà du
matériel dans les hôpitaux surtout de
matériel pour l'eau aujourd'hui puisque
il ya un problème sanitaire très
important vous étiez pour la guerre non
la manif et c'est très clairement la
manif et c'est assez d'accord il pas il
manquerait plus que je ne sois pas
d'accord avec mon
ça serait surprenant qu'un non c'est pas
cher le la discussion nations unies a
été au tour de quoi nous avons la
capacité de désarmer un pays ce pays est
il dangereux on estimé qu'on pouvait
désormais ce pays
s'ils étaient dangereux dans le cadre
d'une action internationale dans le cas
nations unies une autre décision a été
prise la communauté internationale
souhaitait rester dans la nation unie
mais ne souhaitait pas cette
intervention
aujourd'hui la guerre est finie faut
reconstruire dans devant tommy vous
étiez pour la guerre non non c'était pas
contre la guerre comble
j'étais partagé avec jean françois revel
lui était plutôt partisan oui on reçoit
quand vous rentrez à la maison il y
avait là non attention je me tiens à
carreaux 1
si tu crois si on a tenu 45 ans semble
cette fois pour violences mais opinion
que je le rendre fou de colère non pas
du tout mais je dois dire qu'à la
lumière de ce qu'on a vu après comment
ils ont déboulonné la statue de saddam
des atrocités qu'a commise saddam
je voudrais que j'étais pas désolé que
les américains aient fait la guerre
qu'il a remportée en trois semaines le
premier grand projet de renaud muselier
c'est reconstruire l'irak et le deuxième
c'est plus sympa c'est d'organiser la
coupe de l'america marseille près ça
vous a plu
marseille oui la classe ouais c'est
sympa non à beaune accueille iron man
les marchés dans la grande classe
marseillais tu lui demande-t-on chemin
et descend de sa voiture était plus sort
une feuille de faire un plat mon frère
après voilà tu emmènes et 500 voitures
on a quand même la possibilité de on a
un plan d'eau extraordinaire on a une
capacité
sur le plan technique d'accueillir la
kul américain ça sera un plus
considérable pour la france bien entendu
on peut mettre ce plan d'eau à
disposition des suisses et des genevois
et ça donnerait un coup de booster à
notre ville en disant qu'on a mais aka
donc on se donne du mal pour pour gagner
alors on a fait un comité de soutien de
parrainage
on a lancé ça ça se passe plutôt
globalement bien on à zidane johnny
hallyday chirac rhin tout le monde dans
le comité de dans le comité de soutien
oui vive la france vive marseille du lac
où l'américain à marseille alors il ya
un autre truc aussi c'est que vous allez
conduire la liste ump udf contre jean
marie le pen aux élections régionales ça
c'est encore notre combat ça va être
comme ça je vais lui montrer qui c'est
raoul là où quatre fois le bail qu'on va
le retrouver et à prier par petits bouts
façon puzzle
c'est ça non de mettre minable pour
votre beau combat
ouais donc c'est en mars prochain pour
l'instant on a d'autres occupations je
dirais international dans le cadre mon
action au ministère
il est clair aujourd'hui que l'ensemble
des maires de notre région de droite les
trois présidents de conseils généraux de
droite et l'ensemble des sénateurs
l'ensemble des députés souhaitent que je
sois candidat donc on fera ce qu'il
faudra au moment opportun
ouais tu parles trop bien non c'est
peut-être un peu déformé par quai
d'orsay pour l'instant mais je vis tu
reviens moi c'est un diplomate la seule
inconnue c'était musée au premier matin
un diplomate alors sur petit ou au musée
ah c'est lui qui tout à l'heure
enfin
c'est fort ce que tu fous moi ça sent
bien y'a grands arguments que vous avez
renault c'est que vous dites je suis
médecin pour montrer votre pragmatisme
pour montrer votre compassion pour la
race humaine vous dis toujours je suis
médecin si vous pensez que ça rassure
les gens effectivement de savoir que
vous êtes médecin alors on va vous faire
une interview dit docteur alors dit le
docteur c'est quand la dernière fois que
vous avez ausculté quelqu'un à 15 jours
il ya un truc qui m'inquiète la bo fait
de la politique d'un vieillard de sauver
la vie des gens non c'est exactement le
même métier pour une raison très simple
c'est quand on est médecin on s'occupe
d'un patient qui vient que vous explique
sa patte sur son histoire vous essayez
de faire le diagnostic d'appliquer le
traitement et vont regarder ça marche
alors la politique c'est le moment de
parler sauf qu'au lieu devait d'avoir
une seule personne vous avez un corps
social
c'est pas pour faire comme kouchner
n'ont pas de sacs de riz aussi l'asie il
ya plein de toubib à ce que le monde est
malade alors est ce pour quoi ils vous
ont pas mis au ministère de la santé
vous êtes médecin un autre un prophète
un prof ministère de la santé vous êtes
médecin vous êtes aux affaires
étrangères dit docteur ça c'est ça s'est
calmé les scandales d'aidé clinique
marseillaise les chirurgiens qui
s'assassiner entre ça s'est réglé les
plus probables fini c'est fini tout est
sous contrôle com s et à varèse
dites-moi d'acteurs le cannabis c'est
vraiment nocif à part pour mon casier
judiciaire c'est réprimée par la loi
gaffe à ce que j'ai compris mais pas la
loi c'est pas conseillée mais c'est vrai
qu'un pétard égale des cigarettes oui
c'est vrai c'est surtout s'il ya des
problèmes en système nerveux central et
donc à une 6ème d'accoutumance et de
redemande bon donc ça ça pose des
problèmes de l'est contre le mal au dos
va remède souffle chaud dans la nuque à
une douleur violente douleur dans le bas
des reins c'est une technique de
traitement et contre l'extrême droite
c'est quoi votre main l'élimination est
contre l'épidémie de chômage
ça c'est le rôle des politiques pas des
médecins non médecin s'est soigné et la
fin ça va une petite mine en ce moment
non il n'a pas du cholestérol un peu les
ouailles
j'ai pas vu sa prise de sang ouais mais
la vie n'est pas très équilibré quand
même que ça me surprendrait parent et
chirac il est pas un peu crevé là depuis
que les américains ont gagné la guerre
mais je trouve qu'il est moins fort
selon lui leur lutte assez
impressionnant comme il jamais fatigué a
valu ses impressions les no 1 mais un
petit mot marche à quoi sert un
politique un qui aime son pays il aime
ce qu'il fait il le fait l'increvable il
me parle de sa maison à ussat fameux
mais qui sort et buzz au compteur c'est
normal qu'on bond quand on regarde un
film porno et qu'on pleure pas quand on
voit une comédie romantique
si vous demandez pas le médecin est là
c'est donc c'est leur annonce très bien
si nantes comédie romantique ses
missions
olivier
saluer nos deux policiers gomes et du
bois
[Musique]
hu
et maintenant
oh
c'est pas la mer c'est la fibre et si
shirel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas de là tant d'espérances vous êtes
beaucoup beaucoup plus femme que la
dernière fois que vous allez lui sont
passés quand qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
les régler maintenant elle est grande
c'est une grande fille magnifique
magnifique ut alors on a connu jean
manson avec allain bougrain dubourg on a
connu jeane manson avec richard berry le
fameux mariage bouddhistes nous avons
beaucoup parlé dans cette émission au
lieu-dit dias le fameux la fameuse
valise tout à fait vraiment pas de la
télé il que le sommet on a connu jeane
manson avec votre papa andré johnny
voilà voilà ici pour lui d'ailleurs pour
votre papa andré que vous êtes converti
au judaïsme que j'ai remplacé le nom de
jean mister par le nom de chirel shirel
qui veut dire le champ vers dieu mais
ceci étant vous avez bien fait parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous seriez 2 jennifer de
la chanson ou quoi dans la vie il faut
suivre ce que ma mère voulait que je
m'appelle jennifer bien sûr ne change
pas mais j'ai suivi maturité botella je
suis franc un an et demi qu'on s'est pas
vu mon bébé ça va j'ai eu peur en venant
ici pourquoi haché pas j'ai fait les
prières et où je vous assure huawei a
non à ce point mais pourquoi bat pour
que ça se passe bien que ça cuit une
bonne harmonie une veut ne sais pas
qu'est-ce que j'ai posées moi je sens
des bonnes vibrations
on est détendu et bien il ya un petit
problème a quand même merde comment on
va gaiman est ce que j'ai et bissé
d'ailleurs non alors il vit ça veut
toujours gagner mais de l'ensemble avec
quelqu'un je sais pas j
bah oui mais non
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis les panneaux et aquacoles et
rançon plusieurs os non quand même pas
on sait pas non non non ils auront alors
qu'on est plus loin cette fois ci je
mets mon jeu c'est fini je l'écrivais
l'année dernière je ne le ferai plus je
ne le serais plus rien dire ou pas non
non il ya rayah je sais pas je suis
désespéré parce que l'année dernière
quand il tout ce truc autour de galles
et je me voyais avec un garçon dans la
brume diaghilev vous êtes magnifique et
lui s'étaient pagaille est horrible
c'est pas très sympathique dont ceux qui
vit à l'orgueil voilà c'est fini avec
game et juan manche l'embrasser je suis
bien content ça c'est la meilleure
nouvelle depuis longtemps
et alors là vous êtes tout seul quelques
mois ici je sens bien très chaude je te
croire
[Applaudissements]
les journaux c'est un petit brugnon qui
ne demande qu'à être croquée maintenant
on prend des métaphores
d'ailleurs il a dit n'avoir n'arrête pas
de la regarder depuis tout à l'heure
j'ai dit oui oui vous la trouvez le joli
nom elle est devenue femme maintenant
elle est vraiment incroyable à une
magnifique la réplique à alexis pariez
d'une vache large une fois merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma punition bien alors je vais
essayer de faire cette émission
normalement et ça va pas être facile qu
elle croyez le bien
donc qu'est-ce que vous faites après
l'émission c'est des questions à la
congrégation
bon on vous a connu shirel comme
esmeralda dans notre dame de paris
mais aujourd'hui c'est un grand soir ça
ce que vous revenez shirel avec votre
premier album voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça s'appelle tous les chemins c'est le
premier album solo de chirel en
collaboration avec didier barbelivien le
premier single s'appelle à 17 ans c'est
dans
aussi que le jour qui vient ma première
fois sur en souriant
tu auras des clichés qui prend
tous deux vivent
différents
ce sens plus forte ou lucienne sens
nous sommes
le corps
et déjà - son nom
mettez
c'est à 17 ans et yann arriva c'est une
chanson de mariage est une reprise james
hier 70 et chanter ça aussi pas chez
reyl pour fêter votre premier album
je vous ai réservé une surprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire moi interview jean manson
[Musique]
comment ça vanne shirel donc tué ma mère
ça va bien ma main moi tu m'appelles pas
trop en ce moment quand même du bien
dormir presque tous les soirs à la
maison maman avant je lui en fais toi
aussi
dis moi c'est à cause de moi tu es
devenue chanteuse non c'est grâce à toi
aussi tu crois que les gens mon vol non
j'espère pas tu le vis bien d'avoir une
maman connu oui parce que c'est la seule
que j'ai je laime comme elle et moi même
si elle est plus très connue elle est
très connue mais merde tu vois la même
école tu me trouves encore joli très
belle je te dédie ce matin d'ailleurs
anti terme et en plus c'est matin j'ai
dit maman tu es très belle tu me le dire
encore atteint oui même le soir commence
à changer
c'est passé huit heures l'arrière la
tronche et calathes amer j'ai raté quoi
dans ton éducation shirel quelle
question sa présence m'a peut-être
manqué parfois mais tt ou [ __ ]
j'étais en train de jarrat mariage
bouddhiste avec richard berry et je le
regrette maintenant se quittera plus
jamais ma chérie
ta maman se jure et l'éducation sexuelle
tu as fini par comprendre là ça y est
oui oui je pensais avec les faits les
chansons que tu chantes j'ai compris bon
je te demande pas comment ça va avec
gueye est nouveau c'est vrai qu'il est
animateur à la télévision
ouais il est très sympa mais je crois
que tu le connais déjà
ouais vide un peu vieux quand même non
tout est dans la tête
maman qls est vide on t'appelle une
aventure avec barbelivien mois un an
quand même pas c'est comme mon père et
moi je suis raide quand je serai vieille
tu mettras pas dans une maison de
retraite avec l'autre sarraute jamais
moi j'ai été gentil avec toi tu ardisson
très sympa jusqu'à maintenant tu penses
que tu vas
[Rires]
chez eux
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je pense comme on l'était jaloux
de ceux gaye l'année dernière que là
d'un seul coup il a disparu et qui a
percé en premier c'est parce qu'ils
habitent mais ce que c'était difficile
voici sacha distel
[Musique]
jadis très bon soir alors ces achats
vous souriez je me souviens d'un jour où
vous étiez invité dans souffre ou
l'émission de christine bravo il ya une
dizaine d'années et et joëlle goron
avait dit 'est-ce qu'il sourit parce
qu'ils les lifts et parce qu'il est niée
ou parce qu'il est content et quand vous
étiez arrivé sur le plateau
vous avez rappelé que sur le tournage de
sans mobile apparent de philippe labro
on vous interdisait de sourire parce que
vous souriez tout le temps c'est fait
c'est moins fatigant de faire la gueule
ouais pourquoi n'y a plus de muscles qui
travaille quand on rencontre ont fait la
gueule la whey est ce qu'on m'a appris à
l'école on nous a dit qu'il y avait
combien de muscles à 72,3 pour avons
fait la gueule et cinq ou six cantons
riches alors sacha vous avez fait donc
le sachent à chaud de 62 à 72 la belle
vie évidemment en 85 donc cette année là
et après enfin au moins en france on
vous a jamais plus vu à la télé ça vous
manque depuis animé des émissions de
télévision
oui oui vous avez bien ça moi aussi
j'aimais bien ça mais en fait on en
comptait actuelle ce sera peut-être plus
difficile la place aux jeunes c'est
toujours un mètre soixante quinze pour
75 kg cède 1 m 74 pour 74 kg jeudi il a
70 ans attend un bébé à côté
dans cette histoire
70 ans et c'est non ben oui ces achats
vous êtes né en 1933
votre père s'appelait lieu line et votre
mère en bray potter était d'origine
russe est venu en france au rang de la
révolution bolchévique en 1917 d'ukraine
exactement là ça faisait rigoler tout le
monde parce qu'ils étaient d'odessa et
odessa en russie ça la réputation qu'a
marseille en france à mon bonheur
et puis muselier éliminations de
marseille la plus belle ville du monde
alors au début de la guerre en 1939 vous
avez six ans à l'école dans le 16e
arrondissement et vous vous rendez pas
trop compte de ce qui se passe en fait
au début
39 40 et puis le 7 février 1942 vous
venez d'avoir neuf ans et au petit matin
la police française vient arrêter votre
mère andrée qui était juive
la police française c'est à dire le
commissariat chardon lagache juste juste
à côté de chez vous alors un moment
votre mère se dit je vais me fuir par la
porte arrière de la cuisine mais il y
avait aussi un garde à la porte arrière
de la cuisine pas de fuites possibles
votre père essayer de leur raconter des
histoires ça marche pas et vous déjà
vous faites le petit singe savant jeu de
piano ouais c'est les amadouer mais ça
parle ça pouvait pas voir beaucoup de
talent à ce moment là ça va marcher
alors votre père décide de vous éloigner
il vous envoie le collège de l'immaculée
conception à laval en mayenne
vous restez là pendant toute la durée de
la guerre on du débarquement si la
panique générale évidemment et vos
grands parents maternels vous retrouve
vous emmène à pithiviers où ils ont loué
on de campagne et là il ya un chemin qui
fait à peu près 150 m de long et 1 matin
c'est l'heure du petit déjeuner vous
voyez arriver au bout du chemin
deux personnes que vous ne vous ne
reconnaissez pas vous les voyez
s'approcher la dame des cheveux blancs
ne vous la reconnaissez pas et plus ils
approchent de vous et plus vous prenez
conscience que c'est votre mère oui les
parents qui miraculeusement avait
réchappé de ces choses horribles qui
serait ce qu'à ce moment là cela vous
laisse tirer tous les deux dans vos bras
et et vous comprenez que c'est
finalement la seule chose vraiment
importante
c'est évident c'est bon on vous en
parlait jamais de ça oui je pense que
y'a rien d puisque toutes ces histoires
là de guerre continue maintenant donc de
crier au loup ça continue non j'en parle
plus je pense qu'il n'y a rien à dire de
plus nous je sais pas parce que moi je
vous ai vus depuis toujours souriant
bonne humeur charmant important du
bonheur aux gens de la joie nombreux
gens de ce tome est et canton c'est
cette expérience que vous avez vécu d'un
seul coup ça donne encore plus de force
à votre bonne humeur
oui peut-être je sais pas je pense que
mes parents sans ce moment s'est bien
remise physiquement après puis qu'il ait
la vie continue comme on dit en amérique
2 h la messe dans une vrai spectacle
continue mais le spectacle continue
parce que là il ya un rebondissement
absolument incroyable votre mère était
la soeur de ray ventura raison tuera et
ses collégiens chef d'orchestre de
variétés et elad voilà vous allez grâce
à ray ventura mettre un pied à l'étrier
il va vous envoyer aux états unis pour
vous frotter au show business
international et vous reprendrez dire
par la suite beaucoup de chanson de ray
ventura et des collégiens que j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire partie de cet
orchestre et j'étais trop petit quand ça
s'est arrêté
et puis en plus mon oncle est mort dans
des circonstances un petit peu en vain
petit peu oublié un petit peu abandonné
et j'ai toujours eu envie de faire un
jour induira normal
j'ai fait il ya huit ou non j'ai remonté
un orchestre comme ça et
[Applaudissements]
barilla
sucden
ça vaut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya de l'espoir en nous
alami
m
[Musique]
parker
voilà sacha distel bank a repris les
chansons ne sont donc gérés ventura
alors ça c'est la première époque donc
ray ventura et puis après avant de
devenir le crooner qu'on connaît vous
avez tout un tas de tubes à céret
ventura quand même des poires
résumé
v
[Musique]
ayalon
oh
[Musique]
jamais
d'avoir
jean
[Musique]
avec une chambre
à cela
[Musique]
m
perçant rappel du ans
[Musique]
ça c'est marilyn et vit bien
il
edano
c'est voler
c'est comme ça pourrait changer tout ça
j'en ai assez de respect tout seul à la
maison
à tournai toujours en jeu
[Musique]
tu
on
c'est à travers ça que je vous ai connu
et avec mon petit frère quand j'étais
tout petit il y avait eus et on faisait
des petits numéros mes parents à quatre
pattes habeshia donc très bien déjà à
l'époque mais voilà alors ça bon après
il ya le sacha distel crooner là c'est
autre chose
en vain
sans soucis sans problème
[Musique]
sans la
on est triste et honteux
une anti rayures jaunes
j'ai trahi notre ami
[Musique]
quand
tu te la pluie tombée sur moi
moi
tout
sur moi
shania
tu es le seul
e
[Musique]
tu es le soleil de mes jours l effort
luwak est produit en les one a ici
ce périple m
elles devront denner oui
récit
[Musique]
à mes yeux
un essai
moelleux ou
des fous rires on pouvait
arrêté le temps sur la tempe
e ton sourire
c'est ouvert
europe 1
sacha distel symphoniste est donc les
trois derniers morceaux sont issus du
nouveau cd de sacha distel qui s'appelle
envers et contre vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est un double album il ya
quatorze chansons inédites en français
les musiques samson de vous est donc la
dernière chanson qu'on a entendu c'était
donc avec john warwick
ça s'appelle si l'on pouvait arrêter le
temps
arrêté le tour
que ce soit un an
je taux longs
thierry orlando hexis l'équipe
oui oui
[Musique]
arrêté le temps richier jeu
ce que le riz
[Musique]
on ne tue pas
brecht
elle aime ça
m
sacha distel on est contre vous alors ça
tient que sur le cd
en france et donc la musique est debout
et puis un deuxième cd donc avec les
grands standards américains avec en core
2 duo avec diane warwick et un duo avec
la liza minnelli oui on a mélangé un
petit peu là le jazz que les temps avec
le côté symphonique
mettez en bulgarie a enregistré 60
musiciens orchestre symphonique pour
toutes ses chances
donc c'est vraiment un plaisir immense
d'avoir fait ce disque c'est génial
alors avant tu vois c'était lui le lover
maintenant c'est toi aujourd'hui l'image
du père maintenant c'est west mais
maintenant il a la classe et il n'a pas
bougé
une telle rumeur lui s'est tapé tout il
s'est tapé bardot et sea taper jeanne
moreau il s'est tapé tout quand je te
dis je regardais les émissions de
marithé françois girbaud un rien à dire
on en parle toujours du jeunisme et on
dit toujours rien n'a pu que pour les
jeunes mais on pourrait parler du
vieillissement aussi parce que regardent
salvador sacha distel tout ça c'est ce
que sont les gens il ya des gens super
bravo c'est bien elle dit excuse moi
mais c'est un énorme déchet parce qu'en
réalité là je compte énormément
c'est pas vrai mais non je trouve que
les gens moi je m'en fous de leur âge
c'est ce qui représente c'est ce qu'ils
ont c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'ils
expriment surtout quoi sécuriser les
nuits je te remercie laurent la semaine
prochaine ce qui fait non la surprise
albert bien sacha distel on va faire
maintenant une interview permis de
conduire non
encore faut
croix et casseroles
quelque part
[Applaudissements]
merci daniel je vais vous libérer merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous comment
ça va alors mais moi ça va bien qu'est
ce que vous faites en ce moment ben
comme d'hab des animations j'ai des
idées de l'émission qui n'aboutissent
pas je fais un émissions de co à daniel
et moi ça m'est égal je la keller nommée
coup d'y passer maître dégage tu vas
rien texas et d'épouvanté 20 en plein
coeur disent que tu veux maintenant on
sait déjà fait les vingt ans va attendre
que tu veux quoi apprendre times non
seconde partie de soirée troisième
partie de soirée la troisième partie
d'accord pour prendre vie alors
j'attends que qu'ardisson les c'est lui
et non qu'il décède qui ne travaillent
plus puis je viendrai ville entend alors
j'avais un talk show
j'aime je trouve que les taux que tout
s'est bien passé
[Musique]
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
je prends
choquée
ciara beatriz barros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh là là là ouais ouais ouais comment ça
va bien une fois très bien tu parle
français
non à une traductrice alors il est
traductrice elle s'appelle comment la
traductrice elle s'appelle corinne salut
coréenne bonsoir thiery donc vous parler
portugais en fait si je parle beaucoup
je parle peu des baby g morges tamo
rouge ce vendredi tous les vingt dix il
parle oui j'ai porté par le portugais
c'est bien là le problème
elle du souci à se faire nommer milla
non non non non non non non non non non
alors qu'eric oui
concentre toi oui alors vous êtes
brésilienne je suis brésilien
alors dites-nous va c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
muzeau la tiba ana beatriz votre
histoire a l'air d'avoir été inventée
par un débutant du service de promotion
et il va vraiment falloir trouver des
aspérités pour donner un peu de matière
à votre biographie
pour le moment c'est un petit peu lisse
dont on va falloir que vous nous aidiez
parce qu'il faut quand même rajouter un
petit peu de dépit à cette biographie je
compte sur vous je compte sur vous
laurent aussi pour m'aider alors vous
êtes né à iqt à abira une petite ville
brésilienne le 29 mai 1982 ensuite avec
vos parents et vos soeurs cadettes vous
partez à rio jusque là rien
d'extraordinaire
le directeur de l' agence de mannequins
élite vous voit il passe ses vacances au
brésil
il vous encourage à vous présenter au
concours élite look obtenir jusque-là
rien d'extraordinaire en 96 et 14 ans
vous arrivée première au concours élite
et élite vous signant un contrat
tout ça est très voilà et quand il
reçoit votre bout que paul marciano le
patron des jeans guess c'est qu'il a
trouvé la nouvelle figure de proue pour
sa marque
voilà oui c'est pas mal mon phase
cruciale ses classiques comme parcours
n'en 14 ans huawei mais bon tu veux
qu'on l'annulé maintenant c'est chiant
je voudrais je suis sûr c'est un garçon
ça c'est une accroche thierry un truc
intéressant c'est déjà plus intéressant
vas-y fouilles vous fait la pub de
chanel la couverture des plus grands
magazines ils escaladent la douter filet
pour les plus grands couturiers
sérieusement ana beatriz ses pattes
voilà c'est un peu c'est formidable ce
qui vous est arrivé est banal connaissez
court parcours classique qu'aux classes
et un parcours classique
[Musique]
j'ai commencé très jeune a 14 ans
c'était très difficile et j'étais très
jeune je n'avais pas d'expérience j'ai
grandit au fur à mesure j'ai appris à la
grande île a très vite très rapidement
c'est une carrière il ya beaucoup de
compétition il ya beaucoup de monde sur
les marchés il a de très nombreux
mannequins
enfin des filets par exemple il ya
quatre mille chinois qui se présentent
puis vint place donc il faut être malin
et travailleuses à ça qu'il faut
travailler dur pour moi je dis pas que
c'est pas bien c'est vrai que c'est
formidable parce qu'elle a été violée
par mon père n'a pas pu pour espère t on
grâce à dieu nantes par votre frère tout
ça c'est bien la voix sexy tantôt le
portugais lc ball partout magnifique
non mais c'est pas par exemple vous
aimez bien le plat brésilien là comment
ça s'appelle la fed
voilà qu il attend des données corrigées
de psa ont été piqués comme ça ne
t'emballe pas j'aurais dit que le brésil
a été cinq fois champion du monde au
foot et quel temps malade
c'est vrai j'ai avec elle j'ai toujours
été pour le président mais maintenant
c'est cap verdien le régime ouais par
tous les cas un à béatrice pour la pour
la presse il faudra trouver des trucs un
peu plus rock'n'roll sale goût des axes
proches
bah oui les gens de légende ça se fait
pas avec lui demandez lui s'il a quelque
chose de rock'n'roll aime raconter sur
lui
moi j'ai plein de trucs à raconter
raconte moi
j'ai été violée par mon père à l'âge de
huit ans qu'on fait alors l'expérience
comment était-elle très excitant manutan
à 17
[Musique]
il y a
oh
m
famille
[Musique]
une
oh
mais ce cadeau
m
cela
[Musique]
mackay
ah ouais
[Musique]
évidemment quand on la voit jamais ça
1 comment tu l'as trouvé ministre grec
des affaires étrangères
oui il allait au brésil dans pas
longtemps j'y vais à la fin du mois sao
paulo je vais moi je regarde mais il est
fort ce musée vous avez un petit copain
matin oui il à m il a tué cinq personnes
voilà abadie non non nous a raconté à la
presse
alors ce qui serait génial mais je vais
vous dire belle comme vous êtes c'est
qu'elle tombe sur un prince sur un
prince ou ou sur un sur un roi veuf ou
ça serait bien pourquoi un roi veuf
c'est plus facile que marié ou à prince
regard albert on va voir tout de suite
on va faire une interview rennes
[Musique]
alors on à béatrice ça vous dirait de
faire une carrière de princesse ou de
rennes
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas je n'ai rien
contre il ya des princes qui vous
plaisent nous est tombé lui le prince
william le prince william à ce métier
princesse est ce que vous couchez relié
avec votre poissonnier
parce que c'est ce que j'aime pas trop
les odeurs de poisson est ce que vous
seriez avec votre garde du corps si vous
étiez princesse avec le gardian
peut-être parce que ça c'est excitant
aaa joue bien mieux là hein vous n'avez
pas envie de chanter non voire est
terrible c'est la pire vois que tu n'es
jamais entendu essayé comme un ouragan
qu'un maillot
adam alors ce n'est même pas écoutable
si vous étiez rennes est ce que je
pourrais être votre conseiller intime
[Rires]
j'y réfléchis je regarde ton visage et
j'y pense qu'ils sont un petit peu
pourquoi pas à la baisse
eloi ouais tu voulais c'est fier
monsieur le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères mais je crois vous
allez allez rapidement au brésil à ses
émission et admission piège aurait été
intéressante
ouais hier de tanger air sont
passionnantes ouais merci ces derniers
jours
[Musique]
et maintenant moi aussi
je veux
voici dominique labarrière
[Musique]
demi-clé vermont soient emballées 2
on va parler de pierre bérégovoy donc
pierre bérégovoy le 1er mai 1993 il y a
eu dix ans cette semaine
vers 18h sur la berge dans un canal dans
une commune limitrophe de nevers qui
s'appelle sermoise une balle de 357
magnum fracassé son crâne voilà
l'histoire
il avait 68 ans quelques semaines plus
tôt il était encore premier ministre de
ce pays
la thèse officielle c'est le suicide
effectivement trois mois plus tôt le
canard enchaîné avait révélé que pierre
bérégovoy s'était vu attribuer par un
ami de françois mitterrand qui s'appelle
roger patrice pelât un prêt sans intérêt
de 1 million de francs pour acheter un
appartement à paris et lui l'ancien
employé du gaz de france modèle de
probité de vertu étaient devenus
complètement parano et pendant la
campagne des législatives il avait été
souvent accueillis par des banderoles où
étaient inscrits béret tapas en briques
ensuite la gauche perd les élections
bérégovoy démissionne tout le monde le
laisse tomber et ils se suicident ça
c'est la version officielle vous
dominique labarrière vous n'y croyez pas
et vous publiez à la table ronde
cet homme a été assassiné la mort de
pierre bérégovoy
quant au soir des obsèques françois
mitterrand déclare cet homme a été
assassiné
il veut dire médiatiquement vous vous
dites physiquement cette thèse du
suicide ce qui me surprend c'est que dès
20h et d'affirmer oui ce qui est très
rapide
maryse 8h10 vous le disiez 20 heures il
ya plus aucun doute cet homme s'est
suicidé
j'ai trouvé ça d'abord indécent et j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait une rapidité là
dedans qui était un peu suspecte
on se donne la peine de vérifier les
choses c'est la première anomalie dans
cette affaire qui en comporte énormément
moi je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui est
celle qui a cherché le quai chercher le
mois du monde à faire des révélations
je fais un job journalistique ça
consiste à dire voilà le dossier
voilà l'état des lieux voilà ces
incohérences et insuffisances ces zones
dont je les exhume une à une
à partir de ça je j'en arrive à la
conclusion logique froide clinique que
la thèse du suicide n'est pas cohérente
et n'est pas convaincant s'il s'agit pas
d'un suicide il s'agit d'autre chose
c'est pas à moi de dire ce dont il
s'agit c'est à la justice de faire son
job c'est elle reconnaît qu'il ya des
incohérences auquel avec plus loin faut
qu'elle ouvre une véritable enquête tout
à fait alors dans votre livre vous
isolez comme ça neuf zones d'ombré
d'abord le 357 magnum
oublié par le garde du corps de pierre
bérégovoy dans la boîte à gants de la
voiture
alors que tout le monde sait qu'il est
dépressif premier point oui c'est le
premier point c'est à dire que voilà un
garde du corps qui s'occupe de quelqu'un
qu'on lui signale comme étant fragilisés
et qui commet cette erreur que je veux
bien comprendre de laisser son arme dans
la boîte à gants là où je comprends mal
ça pèse le poids de 10 téléphones
portables vous vous sortez de ce studio
110 téléphone portable vous devez vous
en avez
percevoir vous êtes un professionnel
c'est une série de chocs raza c'est le
premier point d'orgue le garde du corps
qui va faire un tour en laissant
bérégovoy avec le flingue dans la boîte
à gants ensuite il ya eu deux coups de
feu oui ce qui pour un suicide
effectivement enfin est assez inhabituel
une de coups de feu parce qu'il ya deux
témoins auditifs qui ont entendu deux
coups de feu
un personne n'est en mesure de vous dire
aujourd'hui si deux balles ont été
effectivement tirer ce qu'il faut même
pour moi c'est très inquiétant
on prend là mon labo lamy au scanner on
est capable de dire s'il a tiré deux
balles
on compte celles qui restent dans le
barillet et c'est très étonnant fin il
n'y a pas d' expertise de cette app
un troisième point le top 6 du corps de
pierre bérégovoy n'a pas été faite à
l'hôpital de nevers
mais à l'hôpital du val de grâce à paris
où il a été emmené tout de suite après
voilà alors 19 18h10 eux on trouve
bérégovoy blessés 19 heures 15 mai à
l'hôpital de nevers 19h30 première
dépêche de la préfecture de nevers
préfecture ce pas le bistrot d'à côté
ouais bérégovoy est mort il s'est
suicidé relayée par une dépêche de
l'elysée à 35 hres du volleyée par
'reuters' à 20h on dément tout ça bien
qu'on voie n'est pas morts on entre
temps on décide de le transférer au val
de grâce on annonce sa mort officielle à
22h10 à la verticale de la balise du
pilier et le top 6 de ce fait de ce fait
n'a pas lu à nevers mais à paris mais
pas au val de grâce
l'institut médico légal personne à ce
jour mais capable de vous dire ce que
contient ce rapport d'autopsié la
famille il a demandé les proches ont
demandé personne n'a vu ce rapport
d'autopsié
c'est incroyable la femme de bérégovoy
n'a pas pu voir le rapport de thenon
n'ont aucune expertise balistique non
plus à des expertises balistiques ont
dit qu on a fouillé par exemple 100
mètres carrés de terrain côté du drame
pour se chercher la balle mandement on a
fouillé le canal vient avec à compter
les balles dans le barillet celle qui
reste est on avait le résultat mais il
n'y a pas de
ya pas d expertise de larmes c'est à
dire que personne n'était en mesure de
vous dire aujourd'hui que la plaie qu'on
voit sur une photo au sommet du crâne de
bérégovoy et bien une plaie causée par
une arme de cette puissance par une
munition de ce calibre et surtout n'a
jamais cherché à définir la nature de la
munition c'est un peu technique mais si
c'est une balle expansive la boîte
crânienne doit exploser désolé de ces
détails macabres
mais le savoir c'est très facile il
suffit d'expertisé l'armée la munition
on ne l'a pas fait alors il ya eu des
tests qui ont été faits avec de la
paraffine pour savoir s'ils avaient les
traces de poudre sur sa veste
oui on n'a jamais eu les résultats sur
la veste nom ait alors maintenant on dit
alors ça je veux bien l'accepter sur
maintenant on dit qu'il ya eu maintenant
seulement maintenant que ça m'apportait
des traces de poudre
la veste a été prise par les gendarmes
elle a été expertisé où on n'a pas la
connaissance du test
alors il ya autre chose aussi qui est
quand même très inquiétant c'est la
disparition de l'agenda personnel de
bérégovoy donc on le voit 20 minutes
avant l'heure du drame
dix ans sur france 3 bourgogne portant à
la main son agenda personnel et après sa
mort on le retrouve plus voilà ça il
consulte son agenda 20 minutes avant le
drame il le remet dans sa poche et après
plus personne n'entend parler de cet
agenda ou plutôt on en attend beaucoup
parlé mais avec des versions
contradictoires elles première version
on est on l'a fait disparaître l'agenda
de pierre bérégovoy
parce que pour donner l'impression que
françois mitterrand ne l'avait pas lâché
on va inventer un faux déjeuner à
l'elysée le lundi ouais c'est à dire
comme ce faux rendez-vous ne peut pas
figurer dans l'agenda
on va faire disparaître l'agenda pour
faire disparaître un nom rendez-vous
s'il doit y avoir un énarque inventé ça
c'est très complexe
alors qu'on pouvait très bien dit on va
il l'a pas notées dans rien agenda parce
que c'est tellement important pour lui
de mener avec ça s'oublie pas résout bly
parent on pouvait très bien s'en est
alors on ne ressort jamais cet agenda
alors il ya une deuxième version qui a
été donné qui dit mais cet agenda a
comporté des choses qui auraient pu
choquer madame perego moi je
je veux bien là tous nos secrets enfin
me enfin je sais pas d'après les
lectures que je fais des hommes qui ont
des secrets les écrivent pas en clair
dans leur agenda plus ou moins codé et à
supposer que j'ai une vie cachée et
qu'elle soit de mon agenda avant de me
suicider je me débrouillerai pour me
débarrasser de cet âge avait justement
on en arrive là aucune lettre d'adieu
pas de lettre d'adieu alors voilà un
homme qui est marié avec la même femme
depuis 44 ans qui l'appelle au téléphone
tous les jours où qu'ils soient quelles
que soient ses charges de pouvoir qui
lui offre le muguet j'ai retrouvé le
fleuriste qui à 13h30 lui offre le
muguet le 1er mai et il n'écrit pas ça
pas il ne laisse aucun mot d'adieu
aucun mot d'adieu il n'écrit pas à son
parti politique comme salengro l'a fait
impression suicide et personne ne trouve
aucune trace de ça alors c'est pas un
élément déterminant c'est un élément en
plus non mais voilà évidemment ça
n'engage que vous mais quand on est
votre bouquin on a le sentiment que
pierre bérégovoy a été assassiné quand
même c'est ma conviction c'est ma
conviction pourquoi coup alors je met
d'accord c'est pas vous comprenez bien
que c'est pas moi de faire ce travail et
beaucoup de similitudes avec affaire
boulin dont les dysfonctionnements de la
justice est nord est dans les
incertitudes avec affaire boulin avec la
fin de roger patrice pelât alors le
problème c'est que bientôt va y avoir
prescription
on était le 1er mai ya deux jours c'est
déjà pratiquement la prescription est il
faut bien qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de
fêtes procédures quand même engagé parce
que s'il ya déjà la prescription c'est
que la procédure a été vivement conclu
est ce qu'il est possible de revenir sur
l' enquête
moi je le souhaite après il faut qu'un
magistrat bouge il ya un fait nouveau
qui est apparue vous savez je vous
écoute depuis la sortie du livre c'est à
dire que un lecteur a compris
l'importance du rapport d'autopsié en
lisant ce livre ce lecteur est un
huissier qui a été appelé par l'institut
médico légal pour constater que le
rapport d'autopsié était bien présent à
l'institut médico légal parce que
l'autorité de institut avait peur que ce
rapport ne lui soient dérobés qu'on ne
le fasse disparaître
c'est quand même extraordinaire la
crainte d'une institution de voir
disparaître ce dossier
et la crainte commencé de voir
disparaître c'est parce que ce dossier
serait gemain conditionnelle assez peu
cohérents sur le plan clinique
avec ce qu'on nous a raconté donc ça
j'en ai informé évidemment le parquet
j'ai fait mon devoir de citoyen qu'est
ce qui va se passer maintenant dominique
je souhaite qu'ils aient quand même un
sursaut et coco qu'on nous dise vraiment
les choses qu'on ne retrouve cet agenda
s'il n'est pas perdu pour tout le monde
il ya bien quelqu'un qui à un moment
donné l'april a eu entre les mains
qu'est-il devenu maintenant voilà mme
bérégovoy est morte malheureusement donc
s'il ya des choses qui peuvent lâcher
l'info produire maintenant qu'on compte
qu'on nous explique exactement de
quelles blessures est mort cet homme
qu'on nous explique que c'est bien cette
arme là qui a tiré et pas une ode qu'on
fasse une reconstitution l'armée dans
une boîte à gants à quel moment la
voiture s'est trouvée sans surveillance
jour là alors quelles ont été les
réactions à votre livre dominique
labarrière alors il ya deux réactions il
ya un petit peu la demande qu la tuera
dont vous noterez qu'elle se précipitent
pas pour rendre hommage à pierre
bérégovoy
aujourd'hui ce qu'un peu ce qu'on avait
c'était un grand ami dit un ami de
façade
ceux qui n'ont pas sorti beaucoup du
hello laissé tomber au moment où on
aurait eu à faire du près d'un million
qui avait pas qu'une affaire tout à fait
légal lingerie a enregistré chez notaire
reconnaissance de tels d'être chez un
autre notaire à nevers déclarations
fiscales à nevers nord tout ça pour
planquer le fric ya mieux pour un
million oui un million un type qui vient
de céder de tunis des finances a dit
qu'il l'a pas volée quand il était
ministre des finances grec preuve
d'honnêteté
alors ça c'est gens là ne m'aiment pas
beaucoup
je les aime pas beaucoup non plus donc
ça tombe plutôt bien mais je moi je suis
à la 9è représentait ce livre et les
gens qui sont les gens les gens d'en bas
comme on dit aujourd'hui vient de me
dire c'est courageuse et bien voilà
l'accueil est plutôt favorable parce que
le travail j'espère j'espère je ne sais
pas moi de dire ça j'ai fait un travail
intègre bien écoutez dominique
labarrière si vous avez du nouveau
revenez dans cette émission
en attendant je rappelle le titre de
votre livre dominique labarrière cet
homme a été assassiné
c'est aux éditions de la table ronde m
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
du lycée entrée donc retrouver jean
françois revel groupe il ay roop il
s'est très tôt le matin
d'accord merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci maman merci
[Musique]
et
m
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
allez
voici brian molko
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alcon placebo brian molko's placebo vous
êtes ici pour votre nouvel album qui
s'appelle sleeping with ghosts
[Musique]
et le premier single s'appelle beach
aranda
[Musique]
thierry rolando exige le quitte
un placebo bitter end
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même génial c'est quand même
génial cette commission parce que sur le
même plateau nous avons brian molko de
placebo et sacha distel voilà cgc fou
alors sleeping with ghosts ça veut dire
dormir avec des fantômes mais s'est
consacré en fait à relation passée qu'on
craint rien qu'un petit rien peut faire
revivre
vous dites on est hanté par les
relations qu'on a eu dans le passé que
ce soit les les anciens amants ou où la
famille quand on fait l'amour essayons
bleus ont peut être
ouais des fois les défunts les fantômes
de daman passé reviennent tenter par un
petit fait l'amour avec quelqu'un
d'autre ça c'est enquiquinant ce tir par
les pieds ouais ouais les gars y
je suis sûr que certaines fois il
apparaît alors c'est cette spiritualité
qu'on trouve dans votre dernier album
est pas et pas très étonnante parce que
vous avez été mystique à ces jeunes
autour de l'âge de 13 ans vous avez été
ce qu'on appelle un born again christian
c'est-à-dire un chrétien rené ouais j'ai
donné mon mon âme à christ à l'âge de 11
ans en fait ouais et rend chose à faire
mais je les fais quand même mais à
l'époque vous aviez souvent voir un
prêtre un bar dit avec lui ben c'était
le ménestrel de notre église ont fait
céder petit séminaire ensemble
moi je trouve ça quand j'y pense parce
que c'est un petit peu étrange est-ce
que le piano qu'il y avait des assume
texte un petit peu un quelque chose
d'autre en dessous lâché patients parce
que les religieux les prêtres rien passé
avec ce non non non il s'est rien passé
bien sûr que non
nous ne diriez sinon bien sûr merci ça
freine une bonne petite nouvelle ça bat
et oui c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure avec un à béatrice est à dire
que c'est important quand on est une
star je dis que j'ai jamais été violée
par mon père avant
alors tout ça s'est arrêté cette
spiritualité ce mysticisme vers l'âge de
14 ans quand vous avez découvert votre
sexualité et je dirais pas que la
spiritualité a été arrêté mais
l' affaire d'amour avec la religion
organisée way we s'est arrêté ouais
quand je me suis rendu compte que qu'il
y avait des sentiments moins que que à
main que mon prêtre ma mère et les gens
de la congrégation étaient contre et je
suppose que là c'était là le début d'une
rébellion qui qui s'est enchaîné comme
une boule de neige un petit peu qui est
voilà est-ce qu'aujourd'hui dans les
dindes jusqu'à jusqu'à presque
maintenant j'ai 30 ans jusqu'à presque
mais trentaine est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes croyant toujours un je pense
vraiment que si on croit qu'ils à un
after life un paradis un qu'on arrête de
vivre que on se dit que la vie c'est une
répète pour quelque chose d'autre moi je
trouve ça dommage
la vie n'est pas une répétition la vie
c'est la pièce même pièce de théâtre
donc là effectivement après ses
expériences mystiques adolescente vous
vivez au luxembourg donc avec un père
qui est banquier américain
une mère qui est catholique écossaise
c'est un peu dur pour vous pas parce
qu'en plus ils refusent que vous vous
inscriviez aux cours d'art dramatique de
l'université brian et là vous vous
rebellez vous vous enfermez dans votre
chambre pour faire de la musique
il n'y avait pas grand chose à sare
luxembourg nous y avait des bons
disquaires alors ouais je suis enfermé
dans ma chambre à coucher
j'apprenais la guitare et j'écoutais la
musique comme info c'était c'était ma
façon de m'échapper de créer mon monde à
moi et vous avez fait votre premier
album dont le titre est assez
significatif ça s'appelle teenage angst
ce qui veut dire l'angoissent
adolescente et danses étaient inspirés
par une discussion vous avez eue avec
votre mère qui vous avait dit dès que tu
sors du vagin tu commences à mourir
c'est une phrase qui est resté avec moi
c'est une phrase qui mentent
ouais encore alors le disque que vous
sortez aujourd'hui va un petit peu plus
loin que les précédents au niveau de
l'introspection non
on a le sentiment que d'un seul coup
vous êtes arrêté un petit peu vous avez
un petit peu arrêter la rock'n roll life
les pétards les sorties tout ça et vous
êtes un petit peu posé vous avez
réfléchi c'est quand on bouffe trop de
gâteau il y en à main après après une
sens centaines
c'est comme ça mais quand même un séjour
si je dirais que c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt la qualité que la quantité
oui il est en train de devenir sage au
bon sens du terme toujours un petit coup
mais j'essaye
18 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut à faire honnêtement ça doit faire
un drôle d'effet comme ça d'être d'être
adulé ouais ça fait un drôle d'effet
ouais ouais c'est dur et c'est dur à
vivre ça 1
c'est étrange ouais c'est étrange c'est
pas nécessairement du ravie elle pleure
les peaux la culture qu'un petit con
hein
la maison c'est tout qu'est ce que vous
pensez de sa brian vous pensez que vous
méritez pas ça ou vous pensez que la
musique que vous faites mérite ça hein
je dirais plutôt la musique que je fais
avec mes frères on est mes frères en
musique mais steve et staff du groupe
qui a plus de valeur que moi en tant que
que personnage médias ainsi que la nana
truc comme ça parce que c'est ça c'est
transparent tout ça et puis ça peut ça
peut disparaître les juges merci avec
messieurs
ana beatriz il vous plait brian molko
j'ai beaucoup aimé ça serait bien pour
votre légende avoir une aventure avec un
mec un peu trouble comme c'est un peu un
peu bizarre un mec un peu trop maquillée
est ce que moi je lui plais nord on
reçoit maintenant philippe sollers
[Musique]
philippe sollers bonsoir donc vous
publié chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle illuminations à
travers les textes sacrés
[Musique]
ça va ça va hein
alors avant de faire le pitch si vous
voulez avoir les noms de ces jeunes
filles philippe peut-être ça vous
intéresse plus que de paraître votre
bouquin tout matériel qui vous intéresse
alors est-ce que shirel vous intéresse
oui bien sûr bien sûr y'a combien bien
est-ce qu'un à béatrice vous intéresse
mais de la même façon est-ce que méline
vous intéresse tout le monde m'intéresse
bien fait je suis vraiment et le dis
vous intériorisez messieurs quel plaisir
de vous voir aussi attendait dit pas ça
parce que sacha distel vous l'avait
allumé un nom aussi sa faune eux mais
c'est pas grave ça qu'est ce qu'il a dit
hier je crois que c'est des conneries de
mes chances pour un peu quand j'ai
beaucoup et comme je suis un admirateur
est un fervent lecteur je les remets
bien alors on fait le pitch de ce
bouquin philippe sollers donc dieu est
il mort
point d'interrogation 2000 vivant point
d'interrogation ou à naître pour
l'interrogation et si ces trois
questions n'en former qu'une et déjà
rien que le pique nique géant dans le
pitch est violent je suis d'accord si
d'accord vous vous couchez mais la
question est les peler et la question
alors si cela vient donc quoi bah c'est
quoi l'histoire le pitch est quoi
l'histoire de l'histoire c'est que par
exemple george bush ari dieu le matin 1
et frappent les gens qui croient en dieu
n'est pas le même que donc dieu est mort
c'est pas bon qu'il exigeait un
philosophe un penseur est l'homme qu'il
faut le dire aujourd'hui de plus en plus
frédéric nietzsche est ce que dieu et ma
psy et les morts ils se décomposent
bonsoir au revoir vous qu'est ce qu'elle
a fait tomber alors sans stérilet
non
justin maman juste au moment où dieu est
mort c'est vrai et que dieu a pu être
interrompue par ce genre de pau voilà
mon dieu est mort aux ennemis non mais
le problème est que c'est c'est en train
de se décomposer de telle façon que il
faudrait voir ça d'un peu plus près donc
deux mois je m'en fiche complètement il
faudrait savoir qui en a parlé de quelle
façon
qu'est ce que ça veut dire où est ce que
c'est sensible est-ce que des poètes
table nous renseigner là dessus ou pas
ou est ce qu'on entendait tout c'est
dans une confusion totale dans une merde
hein pouvant table dans des massacres
jeu quotidien
dieu que dieu moi je m'en fou ce que je
veux voir ces qui a eu une expérience
intéressante à ce propos donc ça
s'appelle unis une association
élimination cette attitude un peu celle
de réponse mais à qui a vu dieu ne
serait ce que le temps d'une
illumination session pas voir à eux
c'est pas voir dieu on s'en fiche c'est
la façon d'écrire d'une certaine façon
avec des mots avec la poésie etc
oui bah les urls oui par définition si
on utilise des mots c'est réducteur
puisqu'on parle de quelque chose qui
n'est pas humain donc le fait de lait de
les réduire en mots on n'arrive pas très
bien exprimé oui c'est vrai
au contraire c'est vrai shirel que dans
votre dans votre 10 une chanson qui
s'appelle jérusalem et dieu vous
l'appelez des points oui parce que dieu
non ça c'est parce que dieu on l'écrit
pas parce que le tram ça c'est le
judaïsme et d'après ce que je veux dire
c'est que pas plus évasive on a dit
qu'il y avait un judaïsme non je moi je
parle au nom de moi parce que je suis
jeune et je vous disais que quand on
parle de jeu c'est difficile de parler
de dieu et c'est peut-être répétitif
parce que justement n'a pas les mots
puisque les mots sont humains par par
conséquent c'est pas divin on n'arrive
pas l'extrait des exo le dessus sur
réducteur de 7,2 cette puissance même si
qui fixe est ingérable c'est parce qu'il
n'y a pas de mots pour l'exprimer on le
ressent quand ce livre c'est une
compilation de textes de prière
r2 de méditation de poèmes issus de la
tradition issue des siècles passés
oui il n'y a pas seulement le dieu juif
qui est important de dieu chrétien que
ce n'est pas mal non plus le dieu
coranique qui fait des siennes en ce
moment curieuse situation mais il ya
aussi beaucoup de dieu il ya des dieux
grecs il ya des dieux il ya un esprit
d'hiver en chine
et puis il ya des déesses qu'on a
beaucoup publié semble-t-il là quand on
regarde votre bouquin c'est vrai qu'il
une espèce comme ça on a l'impression
tous ces dieux sont autour de vous et
comme vous connaissez très bien les
textes évidemment on a l'impression
d'une espèce de communion des textes oui
absolument parce qu'il parle et et des
skis très étrange c'est que des gens qui
sont très distant dans le temps ou voir
même qu'ils parlent des langues très
différent j'en ai les traditions très
différentes se regroupent dans si on
vraiment lié attentivement apic
verticalement se regroupent dans une
sorte d'expérience ou fondamentale alors
il ya quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est que le mot libertin à deux sens
il ya le sens qu'on connaît évidemment
le libertin qui s'intéresse aux choses
du sexe et à la débauche dépravation et
et finalement aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
les hommes là dessus sont battus en
brèche par par les femmes on va le voir
avec notre invité suivante calixthe
beyala qui qui nous livre un texte
extrêmement crue et vous vous revenez je
dirais à la vraie définition du du
libertin au départ au sens premier
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui est capable
d'examiner en toute indépendance les
choses de la religion c'est ça le
libertin au départ voilà absolument se
sait le sens au 17e bah oui c'est
difficile un problème au cou qui apprend
là vraiment qu'il a dit en colère parce
que vous êtes croyants est ce que vous
entendez par là est ce que vous croyez
en dieu puisque vous parlez occupée où
c'est quoi
rentrée du mans non mais est ce que vous
osez les croyants ou pas bon allez c'est
simple vous parlez de gimont diriez vous
parlez de monsieur le commissaire
je vous instruis séduisant par son mari
tim dekay national de dieu voilà il
trouve que besoin par exemple à
s'enrichir elle je pense qu'elles
pensent la même chose et bien ce livre
est fait pour poser la question de la
question suivant il ne s'agit pas de
croire
il s'agit de savoir de quoi tu sèches je
ne comprends pas si vous voulez pas nous
sommes dans une époque dramatique où
tout le monde commence à pour
recommencer à croire ou à faire semblant
de recommencer à quoi moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas de croire je veux savoir
de quoi il s'agit question m'intéresse
oui oui ça m'intéresse de savoir de quoi
dieu ce que ça veut dire à moi que vous
ayez des choses on va prendre là dessus
je serai ravi de vous entendre vous
écrivez moi quelque chose qui soit de 10
chacun positions très personnelles c'est
ce même personnage oui donc on n'a pas
besoin de l'exprimer en mots on n'a pas
besoin de l'expérience ou des brand
était bien non dieu ça doit être des
mots ça vote s'étant le trille un oui
mais maman pas écrit hier par frédéric
c'est dans le mail on la bible par les
proclamations stomie stomie quand le
brésil a gagné la coupe du monde vous
avez vu une équipe du brésil comment s y
met à genoux à la prier dieu ça c'était
quelque chose de beau et là j'ai senti
j'ai senti qu'il y avait quelque chose
vient me foute
mais philippe philippe non mais il ya
quelque chose de pascalien dans ce qu'il
dit parce que pascal 10 mai toi genou
prix et tu finiras par croire vous
voulez absolument analysé dieu le veut
rationaliser et est ce qu'ils sont en
train de vous dire là c'est que dieu
c'est un feeling mois alors dieu c'est
un feeling quand c'est le foot a bien
non j'adore non j'adore moi je crois moi
même je rentre sur le terrain quand je
joue au foot je fais ça comme beaucoup
de joueurs
cela fait donc c'est très bien le sport
c'est très bien mais malheureusement
comme vous savez il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où dieu cerf a à se faire
exploser à ce fléau le sort des femmes
en attendait à ça le dérange je dois
vous parler de je vous parle à dieu bleu
plus profondément déçu quand les ya
plein de croyants qui nous regardent
quand les gens ils prient dieu ils sont
en transe 636 on s'est dit on si je
pense que tu dois y a plus d'intellect à
ce moment là voilà c'est ça qu'il vous
faut laisser un peu de mysticisme sont
laissés un truc mais voici monsieur ça
me dérange c'est ce que j'appelle la foi
du charbonnier la noblesse de la pensée
consiste depuis toujours à vouloir
connaître dieu et à pouvoir en parler
calmement voir avec les mots qui
conviennent contre les sentiments qui
peuvent être est absolument ravissant de
gens qui communient dans le sport c'est
très bien ou autre chose mais je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il ya beaucoup en
ce moment de massac d'explosions et de
violences avec ce mot dieu mais assez
fédérait jusqu'à préférer
si on allait
échéant vers l'avant
anna je vais vous laisser filer pourquoi
pourquoi n'a pas ce que parce que il
faut qu'elle rentre au je vais lui faire
un bisou pour la mois
encore
m
mais
et maintenant
[Musique]
la route
aussi quelques billes
oui
[Musique]
mais ça va bien alors mais je suis
michèle cyr a à aa
fétichiste un peu le cers quand même à
ses pour la philosophe et l'homme créa
la chaussure
camus ça va ça va très bien dans votre
nouveau livre lui alors il parle de
libertinage mais pas au sens solaire
siens du terme parce que lui il est
quand même dans l'idée de dieu et où
vous c'est le libertinage sans ce
sexuelle du terme je crois qu'on peut le
dire à calixte à howie complètement j'ai
voulu m'amuser j'ai voulu me libérer moi
même et voilà j'ai voulu parler de mes
fantasmes
ça fait partie des créations du tube
voilà alors c'est votre premier roman
érotique
ça s'appelle femme nue femme noire et
c'est publié chez albin michel
[Musique]
alors femme nue femme noire départ c'est
un poème de léopold sédar senghor et
vous précisez bien calixthe beyala que
votre style n'a rien à voir avec le sien
c'est vrai que votre style est très
touffu un peu comme une jungle des
serrures d'impact eu un petit fût ce un
peu comme une jungle du donia ou sauve
hostile à ce fait incandescent jédir là
c'est un bol qu'annick j'ai traversé de
pulsions animales tout à fait parce que
j'ai voulu revenir à la sexualité
primaire 1 parce que je trouve
personnellement qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons une sexualité très sophistiqué qui
tue la sexualité cérébrale et il jamais
eu assez je pense qu'aujourd'hui les ans
passent plus de temps à se dire mais
qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir lui
faire que de faire
donc j'y vais arrêtons de parler alors
non mais elle a raison c'est vrai c'est
vrai que l'acte sexuel devenu très
cérébral que intellectuelle est un peu
les hommes impuissants je trouve un
parce que et non mais c'est vrai quand
vous passez votre nuit avec un homme qui
va vous dire qu'il va d'abord regarder
vos chaussures
et puis ensuite après bien sûr il se
sent boba boubou porte jarretelles ou
soutien-gorge et après le reste est à
prix va vous poser des questions sur
votre parfum ou ou sur votre travail
enfin c'est tellement compliqué que j'ai
voulu ramener ça à une simplicité
primaires tout simplement ce sera
quelque chose de vivant à quelque chose
qui est donnée justement par les dieux
j'utilisais exprès le plus réel qui
permet le mâle à la femme de s'épanouir
une chose qui est certaine c'est que la
semaine dernière nous avions sur ce
plateau
christine orban il vous expliquer son
fantasme à elle c'est à dire un mec qui
vient de temps en temps qui parle pas
qu'il a sauté qui s'en va donc
effectivement on a on a bien compris tu
sais un petit peu la tendance du moment
quoi c'est à dire que vous en avez marre
de discuter avec les mecs vous voulez
qu'ils vous baise et vous avez bien
raison nous c'est pareil on appris à la
dure lutte discuter avec vous voilà
alors on vire le pitch a alors c'est
irène dit fu fu qui est une voleuse
paumé qui un jour vol un sac contenant
le cadavre d'un bébé ça commence comme
ça elle s'enfuit et elle tombe sur un
dénommé ousmane avec lequel elle couche
puis aussi elle couche avec la femme
douce man qui s'appelle fatou et c'est
vrai que selon la légende du pays
couché avec une seule c'est un peu folle
ça porte bonheur
donc elle est livrée à des tas d'hommes
cette photo dans des crs livre assez
différent c'est à dire que c'est une
femme dominatrice et une femme qui prend
ne lui appartient pas guy des voix c'est
pas une femme soumise c'est pas une
femme
moi ce que j'aime chez les jets les
femmes ce sont des femmes qui organise
en fait elles organisés profitent de la
situation
organiser sa sexualité je veux dire que
organisé s'est amené n'en gagnent
organisée non je pense que ce qui est
intéressant c'est être la maîtresse des
lieux sains et cette fille est une vraie
maîtresse des lieux soit parce qu'elles
aient fait l'amour avec plusieurs hommes
qu'elle est qu'elle est soumise qu'elle
ait perdu non elle d'ailleurs elle
pousse chaque personnage allé au bout de
lui-même puisque elle les oblige à
raconter leurs rêves leurs enfants
talent leur vie sexuelle
je veux dire que c'est une forme
fantastique pour moi c'est une femme que
je crois que l'arrêt mairie demande un
temps parce que bon là vous nous parlez
vous nous parlez enfant sage kaka
jusqu'à dans ce bouquin mais entendu qui
veut lire vous moi je les écris vous
avez
alors quel passage de laon 3 ans avec
vous et moi ou les panaches 22 quant à
lui choisi
allez-y philippe sollers es22 là je fais
glisser son pantalon le long de ses
cuisses mettant à nu la véracité
animalière de sa nature j'ai le vertige
en brusquant sa virilité
on l'a violent presse est fantastique
ouais il suce marketés soupirs et laisse
échapper et les c'est l'émerveillement
qu'entraîne la prévu
la jubilation que procure la facture
elle aa et lorsque je le déplore que ma
langue s'enroule autour de son plantain
dans un vase il continuera les étonnés
par ce texte de manille dans un arrêt et
maintenant sacha distel va nourrir la
page 68 est ce que voulait bien des
mécaniques le texas à la page 68 68
ces séquences aux époux sont en forme
fait nuit pourquoi les rouges ou les
défauts et livrer des campagnols et
qu'elle découvre page 68 sacha distel la
double pénétration et que tout lui même
précipitation le précédent il se
rhabille quitte la chambre lance contre
le troisième mais sens sont aveugles un
vide sidéral s'est creusé dans mes
entrailles
ouais j'ai faim de plaisir je viens
boulimique de désir comme sinon sexe
s'était transformée en une grotte
voraces
lui trouvera ses nombreuses grottes
khorafi le sorti je me mets sur le dos
feignons le sommeil jouets cartes les
jambes
ouais les abandonne de chaque côté du
lit j'ai l'impression d'être dans une
cérémonie vaudou dans laquelle
d'étranges pouvoirs sont à l'oeuvre
ils ralentissent mais centre névralgique
hrt 2009 recettes paye de la condition
idéale du vrai bonheur
ouais donc non on va s'arrêter là
mesdames messieurs parce qu'après page
166 bien il ya un mec à la fin qui se
disent une poule quand même 170 g
d'éclater la wii parce que je voulais me
libérer aussi louis c'est vrai ils
baisent la poule
ne pensez surtout pas que je les gère je
n'ai pas de désir que je n'ai pas vécu
des choses j'ai vécu des choses
fabuleuses dans ma vie un système où je
vous crois plus mais il ya un truc que
je comprends pas parce que moi moi j'ai
eu dans cette émission princess erika et
princess erika me disais que en afrique
les hommes trouvais ça un petit peu
déshonorant de faire un cunnilingus à
une femme c'est vrai ça pour ça que
tommy pardon mais avait en fait un
morceau qui s'appelle mais ta tête
dedans pour justement incité la cité des
sacres met la tête dedans c'est vrai que
le continent africain un continent très
prude et c'est vrai que paierait livre
comme celui là s'était amené aussi les
afriques et à se libérer jeudi donnait
de la parole sexuée nous sommes sur un
continent où en même temps fait un peu
tout ou pas non plus charrier mais en
même temps on ne dit pas les joueurs
on parie b1 benneteau quelquefois quand
on est vierge on sait même pas ce qui se
passe entre un homme une femme
c'est ça ce continent et je pense que
d'ailleurs c'est le premier livre
érotique africains mais maintenant il ya
un truc que je n'en prends pas la
calixte c'est que en général quand vous
venez
vous engueuler y ait tout le monde en
disant il n'y a pas de noirs à la télé
c'est un scandale
vous avez laissé tomber maintenant que
s'occuper que des histoires de cul non
parce que je sais tu sais quoi vous en
occuper bien mieux comme en ce moment
j'ai regarder vos émissions il ya des
lois par vous en ce moment dans vos
émissions vous les invitez tout le temps
que je dors je n'ai plus rien à vous
dire ah j'aime aussi et je m'occupe de
moi mais moi aussi je vais dire que je
ne vais pas attendre ce sont dix ans
pour pouvoir matière est ce qui est un
mec qui passe par là je m'occupe de moi
même pour l'instant mes désirs nathan
les il ya quand même des moments où
c'est plus doux quand même bien donc je
reprends ce moment le contrôle de
quelque part de mon corps me demande ce
que j'avais et j'ai grandi en perd six
donc ça s'appelle femme nue femme noire
et c'est le nouveau livre de calixthe
beyala chez albin michel
belga la famille
or c'est édité chez albin michel
[Musique]
alors avant de passer au blind test je
voudrais vous parler de reporter sans
frontières aujourd'hui samedi 3 mai
reporter sans frontières célèbre la 13e
journée internationale de la liberté de
la presse
manutan a dit serge danse connaît
oh ça m'a bien non
dingue ça donne quoi
[Musique]
n'attendez pas qu'on vous prive de
l'information pour la défendre
soutenez reporters sans frontières
achetez l'album philippe qui sont pour
la liberté de la presse reporters sans
frontières donc à cette occasion
reporters sans frontières met en vente
un album de photographies et réalisé par
philippe plisson au prix de 6 euros
tout l'argent récolté sera reversé à
reporter sans frontières qui luttent
pour la liberté d'expression dans le
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà on passe au blind test ce soir là
une caisse spéciale fête du travail et
aux platines j'appelle mon ami guy
cuevas
[Applaudissements]
on est deux
le sommet à six bâtons
m
seul
et si bas
à
quand on pense à ce que l'argent comme
un seul mois debout france nous avons
ce d'être autant que nous
guy kowalski a été disloqué au nuage qui
a été dit choqué au 7 rue sainte-anne
dit choqué au palace et ça m'a fait très
plaisir de te revoir mon chouchou
merci boucairie à cet égard le monde ça
va tu es toi comment tu vas ouais tu
mets rajeunie et pour jouer avec nous
rappelle pascal sellem gomez qui est
venu voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors vous connaissez le principe
là quand je veux dire s'il ya la boule
roule à descendre il va y avoir les
offsprings et on va passer aux blancs
thèse didier
[Musique]
tout le monde est prêt mais là j'ai j'ai
l'impression que l'équipe de calixthe
beyala va être plus forte que l'équipe
de chirel ses avocats des gens qui
passent de l'autre côté parce que là
quand même sinon c'est un petit peu
déséquilibre si vraiment pas très fort
ouais alors vous êtes prêt je veux
l'interprète 1 jusqu'au bon qu on joue
par équipe donc l'équipe de calixte
contre l'équipe de chirel attention vous
êtes prêts guy la santé oms bien
[Musique]
un emploi dans l'équipe du sial
attention jeu mais l'interprète dix
erika française et rigueur russell
oslo
[Musique]
attention by ap
[Applaudissements]
difficile à mon avis est que sacha
distel qui peut reconnaître sa tradition
l'impression la pression la pression la
pression sur sa shaggy
[Applaudissements]
g
or nos travaux la batterie donc j'avais
2 2 méline 2 pour l'équipe de calix 2
pour l'équipe de sir à la tension qui
boit
ajout d'un sursis
allez
soufflage le point bas là
[Applaudissements]
il souffre pas
j'ai dix titres pas sifflé par la sas
qu'en soufflant vous donner le point
l'équipe adverse mais franchement c'est
pas bien attention dit machin
[Applaudissements]
je
c'est
[Applaudissements]
enrichir la vie mais c'est elodie
navarre qu'il a vu le plus fort elle
mérite attention dit
[Musique]
pas
on devait tuer
il
tu m'as l'ancien pascal tu n'as pas
trouvé sur la base est pas coincé
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter à temps
nous le dira
les
jouer
donc qu'à équipe effectivement méline
qu'en équipe je crois que c'est l'équipe
de quelle sera la taille de 6 6 points 2
[Applaudissements]
mais l'eau
ouais
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
justement
[Applaudissements]
bien alors maintenant maintenant passer
chacun pour sa gueule montchanin brian
molko en plus j'ai une chanson
internationale j'espère que vous allez
vous rattraper moi si attention dit
[Musique]
parce que
la chanson attention
[Applaudissements]
oui
attention attention le gabon beau
[Applaudissements]
attention le libyen banco le mega man
kogi
[Applaudissements]
ce pas
non
legrand lanka désolé le grand vainqueur
de ce débrayage le grand vainqueur est
passé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'était souvent lanta
sion que tout le monde regarde
avec landes affiche donne ni taxi
brand et le single s'appelle une dame en
prison eh bien avec moi avec fès
seul
non
jacques brenner d'extrémité ici et le
dit d'abord dit of time
et jean yanne connaît
et du bois l'album s'appelle plus faire
la loi et le single s'appelle en tête
en tout cas cela vient
ces plans renaud muselier secrétaire
d'état j'avais un grand joueur merci
chérie
oms appelle tous les
sa peine à 17 ans on voit la salle
choisie soit l'album s'appelle envers et
contre vous et sasha ce grand penseur
les 3 4 et 5 octobre au grand rêve ana
beatriz barros d'une agence ou mal
et bien les coups selon mme unis via
l'arrière cette femme a été assassinée
un ordre bérégovoy enquête sur l'
enquête et j'ai vu
sur de la table ronde brian molko est
placé
[Applaudissements]
ces derniers jo le signale d'abord
on peut les acheter le 18 octobre blogue
rennes 2 lyon lemaitre à marseille le 27
1 kg
val d'oise philippe sollers
nation à travers les textes sacrés s'est
vu
c'est robert laffont et calixte beyala
voilà devenu papa c'est chez albin
michel
voilà c'est
dans l'embarras merci de votre fidélité
on est la seule croissance
qui
[Musique]
m
tout
[Musique]
pas là
genève
[Musique]